THE SENATE
GOVERNMENTAL ORGANIZATION
COMMITTEE WILL COME TO ORDER. I
WANT TO EMPHASIZE THAT WE DO
HAVE 24 BILLS UP TODAY. SO I
ENCOURAGE AUTHORS AND THEIR
WITNESSES TO PLEASE BE AS
CONCISE AS POSSIBLE, BECAUSE YOU
JUST HAVE TWO MINUTES TO SPEAK
DOES NOT MEAN YOU HAVE TO SPEAK
FOR TWO FULL MINUTES. OKAY, I'M
JUST READING THE SCRIPT. I DID
NOT WRITE THAT. SO AND THEN WITH
THAT, I Ó HE WAS SUPPOSED TO
INTRODUCE ME. WHATEVER. HE'S NOT
HERE. I'M HERE. WE'RE GOING TO
START. WE CAN'T DO A QUORUM, SO
WE'RE GOING TO MEET AS A
SUBCOMMITTEE, AND WE'RE GOING TO
GO TO OUR FIRST ARTHUR AUTHOR. I
KNOW IT'S TIM GRAYSON. ONE TIME
I CALLED HIM CHRIS WARD, AND HE
DIDN'T LIKE IT. AND THEN WHEN I
TOLD CHRIS WARD HE DIDN'T LIKE
IT EITHER. OKAY, SO THIS IS FILE
ITEM, FILE ITEM. SIX AB 1296.
AND WITH THAT, SIR, YOU MAY
START. THANK YOU SO MUCH. MR.
CHAIR AND MEMBERS, AB 1296
PROHIBITS STATE REGULATIONS FROM
REQUIRING OR COMPELLING THE SAN
FRANCISCO BAR PILOTS TO REPLACE
SPECIFIED PILOT STATION BOATS
UNLESS THE REGULATION AUTHORIZES
THE REPLACEMENT OF A PILOT
STATION BOAT ONCE IT REACHES THE
END OF ITS USEFUL SERVICE LIFE.
SAN FRANCISCO BAR PILOTS, OR SP,
PROVIDE AN ESSENTIAL SERVICE FOR
SAFELY NAVIGATING COMMERCIAL
VESSELS TO AND FROM NINE
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA PORTS UNDER
CALIFORNIA CODE SP, IT'S
MANDATED TO MAINTAIN A MINIMUM
OF TWO PILOT BOATS IN SERVICE,
WITH ONE BOAT ON STATION IN THE
OPEN OCEAN AT ALL TIMES. TO MEET
THESE REQUIREMENTS, BAR PILOTS
MAINTAINS A FLEET OF FIVE PILOT
BOATS CALIFORNIA AIR RESOURCES
BOARD'S COMMERCIAL HARBOR CRAFT
REGULATIONS EFFECTIVE DECEMBER
31ST, 2024, WILL RENDER SFP
SERVICES NEARLY IMPOSSIBLE WITH
A TOTAL CONSTRUCTION COST OF 68
MILLION. NOT INCLUDING
FINANCING. REPLACING THESE
VESSELS WITHIN THE SPECIFIED
DEADLINES IS NEITHER FINANCIALLY
NOR LOGISTICALLY FEASIBLE. AB
1296 PROPOSES A VIABLE PATHWAY
TO ACHIEVE CARB COMPLIANCE BY
EXTENDING CARB'S DEADLINES TO
MATCH THE SERVICE LIFE OF THE
STATION BOATS. THIS APPROACH
ALLOWS SUFFICIENT TIME TO
COLLECT THE NECESSARY FUNDS TO
BUILD NEW CARB COMPLIANT BOATS
ONE AT A TIME, WITHOUT FINANCING
THE CONSTRUCTION COST AND SAVING
TENS OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS.
ULTIMATELY, AB 1296 WILL ENSURE
THE ECONOMIC HEALTH AND
STABILITY OF PILOTAGE SYSTEM
WHILE ALIGNING WITH CALIFORNIA'S
ENVIRONMENTAL GOALS. AND WITH
THAT, DO WE HAVE? YES, WE DO.
AND I WOULD LIKE TO INTRODUCE MY
WITNESS, CAPTAIN, AN MCINTYRE
BUSINESS DIRECTOR OF THE SAN
FRANCISCO BAR PILOTS. THANK YOU.
I WOULD GIVE YOU MORE THAN TWO
MINUTES, BUT COMMITTEE RULES ARE
ONLY TWO MINUTES. SO WHENEVER
YOU'RE READY. OKAY. GOOD
MORNING. MY NAME IS, CAPTAIN ANN
MCINTYRE. I'M THE BUSINESS
DIRECTOR FOR THE SAN FRANCISCO
BAR PILOTS, AND I APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE COMMENTS
TODAY. SFGP ALONG WITH PMSA.
THANKS YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION OF ASSEMBLY BILL
1296. FIRST OF ALL, WE'D LIKE TO
STATE THAT SP 100% SUPPORTS THE
INTENT OF THE CARB REGULATIONS.
OUR CORE MISSION IS THE
PROTECTION OF THE ENVIRONMENT
AND SUPPORT OF THIS MISSION.
LAST SEPTEMBER, WE TOOK DELIVERY
OF THE FIRST CARB COMPLIANT
PILOT VESSEL IN THE UNITED
STATES AT A COST OF OVER $9
MILLION. IN ASKING YOU TO
SUPPORT ASSEMBLY BILL 20 OR
1296, I'D LIKE TO MAKE IT CLEAR
THAT SFGP IS NOT SEEKING TO ROLL
BACK OR AVOID REGULATIONS.
RATHER, WE ARE SEEKING WHAT WE
VIEW AS THE BEST AND ONLY
ACHIEVABLE PATHWAY TO
COMPLIANCE. AS YOU KNOW, IN THE
SF BAY AND TRIBUTARIES PILOTAGE
SERVICE OPERATES SIMILAR TO A
PUBLIC UTILITY. AS SUCH, PILOTS
ARE STATUTORILY REQUIRED BY THE
HARBOR NAVIGATION CODE TO HAVE
AN OFFSHORE PILOT VESSEL AT SEA
20 473 65. IN PRACTICE, IT TAKES
THREE STATION BOATS TO PERFORM
THIS MANDATE UNDER CARB
REGULATIONS, TWO OF THESE BOATS
EXPIRE AT THE END OF THIS YEAR
AND THE THIRD AT DECEMBER 2025.
LOOKING BACK FROM WHERE WE SIT
TODAY, OUR VIEW IS THAT THE CARB
REGULATIONS CONTEMPLATED THAT
MOST COMMERCIAL HARBOR CRAFT
WOULD BE RETROFITTED WITH NEW
ENGINES AND COSTS. WHILE
BURDENSOME TO BUSINESS, WOULD BE
MANAGEABLE WITH FUNDING
OPPORTUNITIES. UNFORTUNATELY, NO
FUNDING OPPORTUNITIES EXIST FOR
OUR STATION BOAT CONSTRUCTION.
THE TOTAL REPLACEMENT COST OF
THIS PROGRAM, INCLUDING THE
FINANCING, IS ABOUT $84 MILLION.
AND WE'VE REALLY RUN DOWN THE
FUNDING OPPORTUNITIES
EXTENSIVELY, AND THERE'S JUST
REALLY NOTHING THERE. SECONDLY
WITH IT, REGARDING THE ACTUAL
CONSTRUCTION, WHEN THE
LEGISLATOR FIRST STARTED
CONSIDERING CHANGES TO THE
COMMERCIAL HARBOR CRAFT EMISSION
STANDARDS, WE TOOK IT SERIOUSLY.
OVER THE PAST FIVE YEARS, WE'VE
BEEN DEVELOPING THE PLANS FOR
THESE NEW STATION BOATS. WE'VE
BEEN NOW SHOPPING THOSE PLANS
WITH SHIPYARDS THROUGHOUT THE
COUNTRY. AND UNFORTUNATELY,
THERE'S VERY LITTLE INTEREST IN,
BUILDING THESE BOATS DUE TO THE
CARB DEADLINES AND SUPPLY CHAIN
ISSUES RELATED TO, SOURCING
EQUIPMENT, SOURCING NEW ENGINES
FOR THESE BOATS IS OVER A YEAR.
LASTLY, I JUST WOULD LIKE TO
POINT OUT THAT REGARDING
EXTENSIONS, WE HAVE BEEN WORKING
WITH CARB. WE HAVE AN EXTENSION
Ã AN EXTENSION UNDER
CONSIDERATION RIGHT NOW,
HOWEVER, THE EXTENSIONS ARE 1 TO
2 YEARS AND FOR THE BUSINESS
PLANNING FOR THIS TYPE OF
OPERATION, JUST 1 TO 2 YEARS, WE
CAN'T RELY ON THOSE KINDS OF
EXTENSIONS. SO, I'D LIKE TO END
JUST BY REITERATING OUR REQUEST
TO YOUR SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLY BILL
1296. THE NECESSITY TO CONSTRUCT
THREE NEW CARB COMPLIANT BOATS
IS BORN OF A VERY UNIQUE SET OF
CIRCUMSTANCES THAT ARE OFTEN
BEYOND THE SCOPE OF THE CURRENT
CHC. IT'S CRITICAL FOR THE
ECONOMY, THE PUBLIC, THE
ENVIRONMENT THAT WE HAVE AN
ACHIEVABLE PATH TO COMPLIANCE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU.
SHE DID ABOUT THREE MINUTES. I
WAS GOING TO SAY, I'LL BE VERY
QUICK. I HAVE TO BEND DOWN. I'M
NOT GOING TO CUT YOU OFF, BUT
FACTOR THAT IN. THANKS, MR. VICE
CHAIR MATT ROBINSON, ON BEHALF
OF THE PACIFIC MERCHANT SHIPPING
ASSOCIATION, WE ARE THE
CO-SPONSORS OF THIS BILL. I'LL
JUST MAKE ONE POINT THAT I THINK
IS WORTH MENTIONING AS AN AS ANN
STATED, THIS STILL KEEPS US ON A
VERY AGGRESSIVE TIMELINE TO
REPLACE THOSE BOATS. BUT SHE
ALSO MENTIONED THE COST OF THAT
VESSEL REPLACEMENT AT ABOUT $80
MILLION. IF WE'RE ABLE TO
SLIGHTLY RELAX THESE TIMELINES,
IT ALLOWS US TO BANK THE FUNDING
NECESSARY. OUR INDUSTRY, WE PAY
FOR THE REPLACEMENT OF THESE
VESSELS, AND OVER THE LONG TERM,
IT ALLOWS US TO SAVE ABOUT $20
MILLION IN INTEREST, WHICH
BRINGS THE COST OF THAT
REPLACEMENT DOWN TO ABOUT $60
MILLION. SO STILL A VERY
EXPENSIVE PROPOSITION. BUT WE DO
HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY HERE TO SAVE
SIGNIFICANT COSTS ON THE PAYER
OF THOSE REPLACEMENT COSTS. AND
SO PLEASE FACTOR THAT IN. AND
I'D ALSO URGE YOUR SUPPORT OF
1296. THANK YOU. THANK YOU. AND
I APPRECIATE YOU BRINGING UP NEW
POINTS. THAT WAS GREAT, ANYBODY
ELSE IN THE AUDIENCE THAT WANT
TO ADD WANTS TO ADD ME TOO,
SEEING NONE. ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION SEEING NONE. PULLING
IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
QUESTIONS, COMMENTS, CONCERNS,
MOVING TO THE APPROPRIATE TIME.
WELL, THERE YOU GO. SO OBVIOUSLY
WE'RE A SUBCOMMITTEE. WE CAN'T
MAKE THE MOTION RIGHT NOW. BUT
YOU HAVE SOMEBODY WHO'S
COMMITTED TO MAKE THE MOTION. I
WILL BE SUPPORTIVE AS WELL,
WE'RE TRYING TO GET DONE BY NOON
HERE TODAY. AND I NOTICE ON THE
DOCKET THAT CHRIS WARD HAS TWO
BILLS UP, CAN YOU PRESENT THOSE
RIGHT NOW? I WOULD ONLY ASK FOR,
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
ON BOTH OF THOSE BILLS. ALL
RIGHT, WELL, ONE OF THEM I CAN'T
GIVE YOU, SO I'M NOT GOING TO
MAKE YOU DO THAT. OKAY. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. ASSEMBLYMAN Þ,
DO YOU WANT TO CLOSE? I'M SORRY
I DIDN'T LET YOU CLOSE. YOU MAY
CLOSE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE. OH VERY, VERY WELL
DONE. OKAY, I SEE MR. LOWENTHAL
IN THE OFFICE AND I MEAN IN THE
IN THE COMMITTEE ROOM, YOU'RE
HAVING YOU GOT A BUSY MORNING
HERE, SIR. SO YOU FILE ITEM TWO,
FILE ITEM THREE, FILE ITEM FOUR,
AND FILE ITEM FIVE, YOU WANT TO
TAKE THEM IN FILE ORDER, THAT'D
BE GREAT, MR. CHAIR. SO WE'RE
GOING TO START WITH FILE ITEM
NUMBER TWO, AB 1135 1135.
PERFECT I'D LIKE TO KEEP YOU ALL
BUSY, MR. CHAIR AND MEMBERS,
VERY PLEASED TO PRESENT AB 1135,
WHICH WILL INITIATE A TRANSITION
AWAY FROM THE USE OF TOLL FREE
LINES, TOLL FREE PHONE NUMBERS
BY STATE AGENCIES AND
DEPARTMENTS, WHILE ENSURING THAT
THE PUBLIC MAINTAINS EQUITABLE
TELEPHONIC ACCESS TO STATE
SERVICES JUST BY WAY OF
BACKGROUND, 30 PLUS YEARS AGO,
WE UTILIZED TOLL FREE NUMBERS IN
A REGIME OF LONG DISTANCE, AND
IT WAS A WAY TO GIVE RELIEF TO A
CALLER SO THAT THEY DID NOT HAVE
TO PAY THE COST OF A PHONE CALL.
AND THE RECEIVING PARTY PAYS, OF
COURSE, WERE DECADES LATER WHERE
NOBODY HAS LONG DISTANCE CHARGES
ANY LONGER. BUT AROUND 20% OF
STATE AGENCIES CONTINUE TO USE
TOLL FREE NUMBERS. WE, OF
COURSE, AS LEGISLATORS, DON'T
HAVE TOLL FREE NUMBERS TO OUR
OFFICES, THE VAST MAJORITY OF
STATE SERVICES DON'T. BUT WE'RE
PAYING MILLIONS OF DOLLARS PER
YEAR FOR THE ONES THAT CONTINUE
TO USE THESE LEGACY TOLL FREE
NUMBERS THAT DON'T PROVIDE
CONSUMER BENEFIT. THIS BILL
ALLOWS AGENCIES AND DEPARTMENTS
TO MAINTAIN THEIR EXISTING TOLL
FREE LINES, BUT REQUIRES THAT
THEY ALSO OFFER NON TOLL FREE
LINES AS THE PRIMARY MEANS BY
WHICH A MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC
CONTACTS AN AGENCY. THE STATE
PAYS PER MINUTE. ANYTIME
SOMEBODY CALLS THOSE TOLL FREE
NUMBERS. THE BILL ACHIEVES THIS
BY REQUIRING AGENCIES TO UPDATE
THEIR WEBSITES WITH THE NON TOLL
FREE NUMBERS AS THE PRIMARY
CONTACT NUMBER DISPLAYED ON THE
WEBSITE BY JULY 1ST, 2025, AND
REQUIRES ANY PUBLICATIONS TO BE
UPDATED WITH THE NON TOLL FREE
NUMBER WHEN THEY ARE NEXT
UPDATED. IT IS IMPORTANT TO NOTE
THAT THE BILL REQUIRES THAT ANY
TOLL FREE LINE THAT IS CURRENTLY
OPERATED BY A STATE AGENCY MUST
CONTINUE TO BE OPERATED WHEN THE
OTHER PROVISIONS OF THE BILL ARE
IMPLEMENTED, THEREBY
GUARANTEEING CONTINUED ACCESS OF
THE PUBLIC. SO IF THERE IS A
PERSON WHO HAS THAT TOLL FREE
NUMBER STUCK IN THEIR FAVORITES,
THEY WILL BE ABLE TO CONTINUE TO
USE IT. THE LINES WILL NOT BE
DECOMMISSIONED. THIS SOLUTION
ENSURES THAT ANYONE WHO IS
TRYING TO CONTACT AN AGENCY OR
DEPARTMENT VIA TOLL FREE NUMBER
CAN CONTINUE TO DO SO, WHILE
CURTAILING OVERALL USE BY
PUBLISHING A NON TOLL FREE
NUMBER AS THE PRIMARY MEANS OF
CONTACT. AB 1135 WILL RESULT IN
ANNUAL COST SAVINGS TO THE STATE
IN THE MILLIONS OF DOLLARS BY
DRASTICALLY REDUCING THE NUMBER
OF CALLS TO STATE OPERATED TOLL
FREE NUMBERS. AS OUR STATE FACES
BUDGETARY SHORTFALLS. THIS BILL
IS A COMMON SENSE APPROACH TO
SAVING THE STATE MONEY BY
TRANSITIONING AWAY FROM
ANTIQUATED TECHNOLOGY THAT
RESULTS IN SIGNIFICANT AND
UNNECESSARY COSTS. GREAT. DO
YOU, DO YOU HAVE A PRIMARY
WITNESS? I DO NOT, MR. CHAIR. I
DON'T THINK YOU NEED ONE. THANK
YOU. SIR IN MY OPINION, ANYBODY
IN THE OFFICE? I MEAN, ANYBODY
IN THE. WHAT IS THIS? A
COMMITTEE ROOM WANTS TO ADD ME
TO TESTIMONY. SEEING NONE.
ANYONE HERE IN OPPOSITION?
BUELLER? BUELLER NO. SEEING
NONE. PULL IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE. QUESTIONS COMMENTS?
CONCERNS SAY IT'S A GREAT BILL.
MOVE THE BILL APPROPRIATE TIME.
OKAY, SO HE WANTS TO MOVE THE
BILL AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME.
I'M SUPPORTIVE AS WELL. WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE? THANK YOU,
RESPECTFULLY, AFTER I VOTE MR.
CHAIR, THANK YOU VERY MUCH. NOW
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON TO FILE
ITEM AB 2375. I WANT TO LET YOU
KNOW THAT THIS IS SUPPORT
SUPPORT RECOMMENDATION. I WILL
BE BRIEF, THESE, THANK YOU, MR.
CHAIR. MEMBERS WANT TO START BY
ACCEPTING COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS.
THANK THE CHAIR AND THE STAFF
FOR THEIR THOUGHTFUL INSIGHTS
AND COLLABORATION. AB 2375 IS
PART OF A LARGER PACKAGE OF
BILLS. THESE ARE THE BILLS I'M
PRESENTING TODAY THAT I'M
CARRYING TO ADDRESS THE ONGOING
AND UNDERREPORTED ISSUE OF
ROOFING THAT IS TAKING PLACE
ACROSS CALIFORNIA, THE COUNTRY,
THE WORLD. ROOFING OR DRINK
SPIKING, OCCURS WHEN A
PERPETRATOR INCAPACITATES THEIR
VICTIMS BY SLIPPING DATE RAPE
DRUGS SUCH AS PHENOL, GHB,
KETAMINE INTO THE VICTIM'S
DRINKS WHEN THEY ARE NOT AWARE
TYPICALLY DRINK SPIKING IS NOT
AN INDEPENDENT CRIME. RATHER,
IT'S DONE TO MAKE OTHER HORRIFIC
CRIMES SUCH AS RAPE, SEXUAL
ASSAULT, EASIER TO COMMIT AND
WHILE ANYONE CAN TURN VICTIM TO
ROOFING, IT'S WOMEN AND MEMBERS
OF THE LGBTQ COMMUNITY THAT ARE
TARGETED THE MOST. DARE I SAY
WE'VE ALLOWED THIS TO GO ON THIS
LONG BECAUSE IT'S WOMEN AND
MEMBERS OF THE LGBT COMMUNITY
THAT ARE TARGETED THE MOST
DURING SPIKING. CAN TAKE PLACE
ANYWHERE. HOWEVER, THE MOST
COMMON PLACES ARE BARS AND
NIGHTCLUBS WHERE ALCOHOLIC
BEVERAGES ARE SERVED. WHEN
SOMEONE HAS BEEN ROOFIED, NOT
ONLY DO THE DRUGS CAUSE MEMORY
LOSS, BUT THEY PASS THROUGH THE
BODY EXTREMELY FAST, MAKING IT
VERY DIFFICULT FOR THE VICTIM TO
SEEK JUSTICE. AFTER THE FACT.
THAT IS WHY PREVENTATIVE
MEASURES SUCH AS THIS ONE, THE
ONE IN THIS BILL THAT ARE
ESTABLISHED, ARE CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT TO SEEKING TO TACKLE
THIS ISSUE. AB 2375 SIMPLY
REQUIRES TYPE 48 LICENSED
ESTABLISHMENTS. THOSE ARE
NIGHTCLUBS AND BARS TO PROVIDE A
LID ON A PATRON'S DRINK UPON
REQUEST, AND TO POST A SIGN
DECLARING THAT THIS IS
AVAILABLE, ALLOWING PATRONS TO
HAVE ACCESS TO LIDS IS A COMMON
SENSE MEASURE TO DETER
PERPETRATORS FROM ATTEMPTING TO
COMMIT THESE CRIMES, REDUCING
LEVELS OF DRINK SPIKING AND IN
TURN, SEXUAL ASSAULT AND RAPE.
AS A RESTAURANT AND BAR OWNER
MYSELF, I'M EXTREMELY SENSITIVE
TO THIS ISSUE. I KNOW JUST HOW
IMPORTANT IT IS TO PROVIDE A
SAFE AND INCLUSIVE, INCLUSIVE
ENVIRONMENT FOR OUR GUESTS, AND
THIS BILL ADDS TO THE
COMPREHENSIVE APPROACH AIMED AT
DOING JUST THAT. I AM PLEASED
TODAY TO BE JOINED BY TANYA
MARTIN FROM THE LBCC, PRESIDENT
OF LONG BEACH PRIDE, WHO IS HERE
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH, ASSEMBLYMAN.
SENATORS. THANK YOU. YOU HAVE
TWO MINUTES. OKAY THANK YOU, SO
I'M HERE JUST TO. I'M IN FAVOR
OF THIS. ABSOLUTELY. AND IT'S
HARD TO BE UP HERE TO SAY THIS,
BUT I WAS A VICTIM, WHEN I WAS
17 YEARS OLD, I WAS ROOFIED AT A
PLACE FROM ALABAMA, SO I WAS
ROOFIED, AND, LIKE MOST GIRLS,
THAT DREAM OF, YOU KNOW, THEIR
FIRST TIME, I DIDN'T GET THAT
DREAM. IT WAS TAKEN AWAY FROM ME
THAT NIGHT, I WAS I WOKE UP IN A
FIELD. A FIELD OF GRASS AND A
LOT OF BLOOD AND A LOT OF SHAME.
AND I KNOW THAT THERE'S A NUMBER
OF WOMEN THAT EXPERIENCE THIS.
AND SOME MEN IN OUR COMMUNITY.
SO I THINK IT'S VERY IMPORTANT
TO OFFER THIS, AND I'M VERY
GRATEFUL. SO THANK YOU. ALL
RIGHT. WELL, THANK YOU FOR
SHARING THAT. THAT'S THAT'S
BRAVE OF YOU TO DO. AND YOU'RE
GOING TO TURN IT INTO SOMETHING
GOOD. SO THANK YOU FOR THAT. IS
THERE ANYBODY ELSE IN THE ROOM
THAT WOULD LIKE TO ADD A ME TO
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT? GOOD
MORNING, MY NAME IS RAUL
VERDUGO, DIRECTOR OF ADVOCACY
WITH ALCOHOL JUSTICE. AND ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA ALCOHOL
POLICY ALLIANCE. WE SUPPORT THIS
BILL. THANK YOU. SIR. ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION SEEING NONE. PULL IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE.
QUESTIONS? COMMENTS? CONCERNS
SENATOR ALVARADO GILL, I
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LOWENTHAL, I'M
QUITE SENSITIVE TO THE ISSUE OF
DRUGGING, AND I WANT TO APPLAUD
YOU FOR BRINGING YOUR PACKAGE OF
BILL FORWARDS, I DO WANT TO
ENCOURAGE YOU TO AMEND ONE
ASPECT OF YOUR BILL, NOT TODAY,
BECAUSE WE'RE NOT, YOU KNOW,
NEGOTIATING IT, BUT I DO NOTICE
ON ITEM NUMBER THREE THAT YOU'RE
REQUIRING A LICENSEE TO POST
POST A NOTICE IN A PROMINENT AND
CONSPICUOUS LOCATION. QUOTE,
DON'T GET ROOFIED. DRINK LIDS
AVAILABLE HERE. ASK A STAFF
MEMBER FOR DETAILS, I UNDERSTAND
THE INTENT, BUT I THINK IT IS A
IT'S A MISDIRECTION TO, AS YOU
MENTIONED, WOMEN AND MEMBERS OF
THE LGBTQ COMMUNITY THAT
ROHYPNOL WOULD BE THE ONLY DRUG
THAT COULD CAUSE INCAPACITATION,
WE NOW KNOW THAT THE SCIENCE HAS
EXPANDED, GHB, GBL, OTHER DRUGS,
SO I JUST $T TO ENCOURAGE YOU
TO BE ALL INCLUSIVE IN EDUCATING
THE PUBLIC ABOUT WHAT TYPE OF
SUBSTANCES COULD BE PUT INTO
THEIR DRINKS, I KNOW THAT THE
TERM ROOFIE KIND OF CAME UP IN
MY COLLEGE YEARS AND, AND WE
UNDERSTAND WHAT THAT MEANS, BUT
I JUST WANT TO BE SENSITIVE THAT
WE'RE CREATING LEGISLATION FOR
THE FUTURE AND WANT TO BE ALL
ENCOMPASSING. SO THANK YOU.
SENATOR ARCHULETA. YES, THANK
YOU. THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD. ASSEMBLY MEMBER, YOU
HAD MENTIONED THAT SPIKING IS
NOT THE CRIME. IT'S THE CRIMES
THAT HAPPEN THEREAFTER, THE
TRAGEDIES THAT HAPPENED
THEREAFTER THAT WE JUST HEARD.
BUT SHOULDN'T SPIKING ITSELF BE
PERHAPS A MISDEMEANOR? AND WE
COULD CARRY THAT FORWARD IN YOUR
BILL THROUGH AMENDMENT DOWN THE
ROAD? MR. CHAIR? YES, I'LL
RESPOND TO BOTH SENATORS, IF
THAT'S OKAY, MR. CHAIR, WHATEVER
YOU LIKE. DRINK SPIKING IS A
CRIME, OKAY? IT IT ABSOLUTELY IS
A CRIME. AND WE RESEARCHED THAT
EXTENSIVELY. AS WE APPROACH
THESE BILLS, IT'S IN COMBINATION
WITH DRINK SPIKING THAT THESE
OTHER CRIMES ARE COMMITTED.
SENATOR ALVARADO GIL, THANK YOU
FOR YOUR COMMENTS AND YOUR
SENSITIVITY. AND THANK YOU SO
MUCH. THIS IS ALL ULTIMATELY
ABOUT PREVENTION, ONCE YOUR
DRINK IS SPIKED, IT'S TOO LATE.
IT'S KIND OF LIKE DRUNK DRIVING.
ONCE SOMEBODY IS BUZZED AND GETS
BEHIND THE WHEEL, IT'S TOO LATE.
IT'S ABOUT PREVENTION. AND FOR
BETTER OR FOR WORSE, THE YOUNG
GENERATION TODAY CALLS THIS
ROOFING AND, ROOFING IS ACTUALLY
VERY SELDOMLY USED ANYMORE. IT'S
MOSTLY KETAMINE. IT'S MOSTLY
GHB, WE HEAR STORIES OF XANAX,
OF OTHER DRUGS THAT ARE THAT ARE
PUT IN AND OF COURSE, DRUGS THAT
CAN BE FATAL, SO IT'S HORRIFIC.
AND I THINK YOU'RE SPOT ON IN
TERMS OF EDUCATING THE PUBLIC ON
THIS AND WHAT THE HOPE IS IN
THESE PACKAGE OF BILLS IS THAT
WE GAIN A VILLAGE APPROACH TO
ALL OF THIS SO THAT EVERYBODY IS
PART AND HAS AN OBLIGATION, JUST
LIKE WITH DRUNK DRIVING RIGHT
NOW, WHEN SOMEBODY SEES SOMEBODY
WHO'S CLEARLY INCAPACITATED AND
CAN'T GET BEHIND THE WHEEL, IT'S
ALL OF OUR RESPONSIBILITY TO TRY
AND STOP THAT PERSON. AND WHEN
WE GAIN A GREATER LEVEL OF
EDUCATION TO YOUR POINT, IT'S
GOING TO BE A COLLECTIVE
RESPONSIBILITY FOR EVERYBODY TO
BE VIGILANT, TO WATCH WHAT'S
GOING ON. THE PRESENCE OF THE
TESTING KITS THAT IS GOING INTO
LAW IN THE NEXT FEW DAYS FROM
LAST YEAR'S 1013 ALONE, SHOULD
CREATE AWARENESS AROUND THIS.
THE SIGNS SHOULD CREATE
AWARENESS AROUND THIS. WE'RE NOT
GOING TO STOP UNTIL WE'VE CUT
DOWN ON SEXUAL ASSAULT. SO THANK
YOU FOR THOSE COMMENTS. OKAY.
I'M JUST I HAVE A CLOSING
COMMENT. COMMENT THIS THIS COULD
ACTUALLY HAPPEN TO ANYONE. A
COUPLE OF YEARS AGO, I DON'T
EVEN REMEMBER FLYING. I WAS
FLYING TWO MIDDLE AGED WOMAN
NEXT TO ME, AND SHE WAS TELLING
ME ABOUT HER EXPERIENCE. THEY
HAVE A SECOND HOME DOWN IN MIAMI
BY A VERY PROMINENT BEACH AND SO
SHE WAS ALREADY THERE. HER
HUSBAND WAS GETTING INTO TOWN
AND SHE GOT ROOFIED LIKE 5:00 IN
THE AFTERNOON. AND HER HUSBAND
JUST HAPPENED TO GET THERE WHEN
IT WHEN IT WAS ALL KICKING IN.
SO THIS COULD HAPPEN ANYONE ANY
TIME. AND WE SHOULD DO ALL WE
CAN TO PROTECT PEOPLE. SO WITH
THAT, YOU MAY CLOSE SENATORS.
I'M GOOD, I'M GOOD. I THINK
SHE'S. THAT'S OKAY. NO. GO AHEAD
PLEASE. NO, NO, WE GOT TILL
NOON. GO AHEAD. WELL, THIS IS
NUMBER THREE, RIGHT? YES OKAY.
SO I WILL WAIT I WILL WAIT TILL
THEM BEFORE. OKAY. SHE'S GOING
TO WAIT TILL NUMBER FOUR. WITH
THAT YOU MAY CLOSE, I FIRST
THING I WOULD LIKE TO SAY IS,
HOW IMPORTANT IT WAS, TO HAVE
MISS MARTIN COME AND SPEAK AND
APPRECIATE HER COURAGE AND
BRAVERY. MOST SEXUAL ASSAULT
GOES UNDERREPORTED. AND THAT'S
THE PROBLEM. YEAH. AND SO, WHEN
WE HAVE SURVIVORS THAT ARE ABLE
TO STAND UP AND SPEAK AND
EDUCATE THE REST OF US, IT'S SO
IMPACTFUL. AND THEY SHOULD BE
CELEBRATED FOR THAT, FOR SAVING
LIVES OF OTHERS. SO THANK YOU SO
MUCH, MISS MARTIN, FOR BEING
HERE. YOU KNOW, THANK YOU,
MISTER CHAIR, FOR POINTING OUT
THAT STORY. EVERYBODY HAS A
STORY. WHEN I SPEAK TO GROUPS OF
PEOPLE ON THESE TOPICS, I ASK
THEM, RAISE YOUR HAND IF YOU OR
ANYBODY CLOSE TO YOU HAS BEEN
ROOFIED WHEN THEY GO OUT. AND
FOR MOST WOMEN UNDER AGE 35,
THEY ALL RAISE THEIR HAND. SO
THIS IS A BIG PROBLEM. WHEN I
PRESENTED THIS BILL IN ON THE
ASSEMBLY SIDE, ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MCKENNA SPOKE ON THE MICROPHONE
ABOUT HOW SHE HAD BEEN ROOFIED
IN HOLLYWOOD. MEMBERS OF MY
STAFF HAVE BEEN ROOFIED. THIS IS
A HUGE, HUGE PROBLEM AND IT'S
GOING TO TAKE A SERIES OF BILLS
AND VIGILANCE, AND WE MAY NOT
GET EVERYTHING PERFECTLY RIGHT,
AND WE HAVE TO REFINE OVER TIME,
BUT WE'VE GOT TO START. WE'VE
GOT TO GET OUT THERE. WE'VE GOT
TO CUT DOWN ON THIS PROBLEM.
WITH THAT, I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR VOTE. THANK YOU SIR.
VERY WELL DONE. NOW WE'RE MOVING
ON TO FILE ITEM FOUR, AB 2389.
AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME, I WILL
ASK C  TO ASK HER QUESTION, BUT
WITH THAT RIGHT NOW. OH, AND I
GUESS THE RECOMMENDATION IS DO
PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS. WITH THAT, THE
FLOOR IS YOURS. THANK YOU, MR.
CHAIR. I WOULD LIKE TO START BY
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE'S
THOUGHTFUL AMENDMENTS. VERY
PLEASED TO PRESENT AB 2389,
ANOTHER CRITICAL PIECE OF THE
PACKAGE OF BILLS CARING TO
ADDRESS THE ISSUE OF ROOFING.
LAST YEAR I AUTHORED AB 1013,
WHICH I MENTIONED EARLIER,
REQUIRES BARS AND NIGHTCLUBS TO
HAVE ANTI ROOFING TEST KITS
AVAILABLE FOR THEIR PATRONS.
PROUD TO SAY THIS BILL GOES INTO
LAW AND, GOES INTO EFFECT ON
JULY 1ST, BUT WE STILL HAVE WORK
TO DO ON THIS ISSUE AS PEOPLE
NOW KNOW THAT THEY HAVE THESE
DEVICES TO BE ABLE TO TEST.
TEST, THE PRESENCE OF DATE RAPE
DRUGS, WE NOW NEED TO BE
PREPARED WITH THE NEXT STEPS FOR
THE UNFORTUNATE EVENT THAT
SOMEONE'S TEST COMES BACK
POSITIVE OR IF SOMEONE BELIEVES
THAT THEY'VE BEEN ROOFIED, THEY
FEEL THAT THEY'VE BECOME
INCAPACITATED. AT THAT TIME.
THEY UNDERSTAND MAYBE IT'S THEIR
FIRST COCKTAIL AND ALL OF A
SUDDEN THEY CAN'T MOVE THEIR
BODY. THEY FEEL COMPLETELY AND
TOTALLY DRUGGED. AB 2389
REQUIRES THAT IF AN EMPLOYEE OF
A RESTAURANT, BAR, OR NIGHTCLUB
IS MADE AWARE THAT A PATRON HAS
BEEN OR BELIEVES TO HAVE BEEN
ROOFIED, AN EMPLOYEE OF THE
ESTABLISHMENT MUST TAKE THESE
TWO ACTIONS. NUMBER ONE, THEY
MUST CONTACT LAW ENFORCEMENT OR
FIRST RESPONDERS, AND OUR
MEDICAL SERVICES. NUMBER TWO, TO
THE BEST OF THEIR ABILITY,
FOLLOW THE INSTRUCTIONS GIVEN BY
MEDICAL OR LAW ENFORCEMENT
PERSONNEL OVER THE PHONE AND
MONITOR THE DRUGGED INDIVIDUAL
UNTIL THESE SERVICES ARRIVE.
WHY? WHY WHY IS THAT SECOND STEP
SO NECESSARY? BECAUSE WHAT OFTEN
HAPPENS IN THESE SITUATIONS IS
THE PERPETRATOR WILL TELL THE
EMPLOYEES OF THE BAR, THAT'S
OKAY. SHE'S WITH ME. I GOT HER
AND THEY WILL TAKE HER OUT OF
THE BAR. AND THAT'S WHERE SEXUAL
ASSAULT IS TAKING PLACE. AND I
CAN TELL YOU, AS AN OWNER OF
BAR, THAT THE EMPLOYEES ARE
OFTEN SO BUSY, THEY JUST WANT TO
GET THE PROBLEM OUT. BUT GETTING
THE PROBLEM OUT CAN LEAD TO
ASSAULT. AND SO WE'VE GOT TO BE
EXTRA CAREFUL IF SOMEBODY HAS
BEEN DRUGGED, THAT'S NOW AN
ISSUE FOR LAW ENFORCEMENT OR
MEDICAL PERSONNEL, THESE SIMPLE
EXTRA STEPS WILL HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO REDUCE LEVELS OF
SEXUAL ASSAULT, RAPE, EVEN SAVE
LIVES. AND AGAIN, PLEASED TO BE
JOINED BY MISS TANYA MARTIN HERE
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. ASSEMBLYMAN, SENATOR. MISS
MARTIN, PLEASE. THANK YOU, JUST
LIKE THE ASSEMBLYMAN SAID, IT
YOU KNOW, MY LIFE COULD HAVE
CHANGED. YOU KNOW, IF SOMEONE
WOULD HAVE STEPPED UP AND SAID,
HEY, SHE'S NOT DOING WELL, YOU
KNOW, THAT WOULDN'T HAVE
HAPPENED TO ME. AS WITH A LOT OF
WOMEN AND MEN, YOU KNOW,
ESPECIALLY IN OUR COMMUNITY.
BEING PRESIDENT OF LONG BEACH
PRIDE, YOU KNOW, IT'S A HUGE,
HUGE EVENT. AND ONE THING THAT I
LOVE ABOUT OUR MEMBERSHIP IS
THAT WE LOOK OUT FOR EACH OTHER.
AND WHEN WE HAVE THESE EVENTS,
YOU KNOW, THAT'S THE ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT WE LOOK FOR SOMEBODY
IS, YOU KNOW, NOT ABLE TO STAND
OR WE HAVE TENTS SET UP AND
SOMEBODY IS WATCHING OVER THEM.
SO I THINK IT'S VERY, VERY
IMPORTANT. SO THANK YOU. THANK
YOU, THANK YOU FOR SHARING.
ANYBODY ELSE IN THE ROOM THAT
WANTS TO ADD ME TO TESTIMONY.
PLEASE COME UP, SIR. THANK YOU
AGAIN. MY NAME IS RAUL VERDUGO.
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ALCOHOL POLICY ALLIANCE, WE
SUPPORT THIS MEASURE AND ASK
THAT THE COMMITTEE VOTED TO
SUPPORT IT AS WELL. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. SIR. ANYONE IN THE
ROOM IN OPPOSITION SEEING NONE.
PULL IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE.
SENATOR CHO EBCLC. GOOD MORNING,
SO I HAD A QUESTION COMING FROM
THE EDUCATION PERSPECTIVE, I
KNOW THAT IF, A TEACHER OR
SOMEONE THAT WORKS FOR THE
SCHOOL DISTRICT, SUSPECTS
SOMETHING IS HAPPENING WITH THE
CHILD, THEY'RE REQUIRED TO BE
MANDATED REPORTERS. HOW IS THIS
SIMILAR OR NOT TO BEING A
MANDATED REPORTER? IF YOU WERE
A, THE BARTENDER, BECAUSE THIS
FALLS UPON THE RESPONSIBILITY OF
A BARTENDER, I'M ASSUMING.
RIGHT. IF I UNDERSTAND
CORRECTLY, A BARTENDER, IT COULD
BE A SECURITY PERSONNEL. IT
COULD BE THE MANAGER, IT COULD
BE ANYBODY THAT'S WORKING IN
THAT ESTABLISHMENT, THAT'S IN
THE BUSINESS OF SERVING ALCOHOL.
AND THAT ALCOHOL HAS EITHER BEEN
SHOWN TO BE SPIKED BY ONE OF THE
TEST STRIPS THAT'S AVAILABLE, OR
THE PATRON BELIEVES THAT THEY'VE
BEEN DRUGGED AND IS GOING
THROUGH IT AT THAT MOMENT,
ANYBODY THAT WORKS IN THE BAR,
IF THEY'RE NOTIFIED, THEY MUST
CALL 911. SO THE SO, JUST KIND
OF CURIOUS ON THAT. ARE THERE
ANY LIABILITIES ON PLACE ON YOU
KNOW, IS THERE ANY LIABILITY OR
PERSONAL RESPONSIBILITY FOR
THESE INDIVIDUALS IF THEY DON'T,
IF THEY IF THEY'RE MADE AWARE,
BUT THEY DON'T FOLLOW THROUGH,
OR IF THEY DON'T FOLLOW THROUGH
WITH ENSURING THAT THE PATRON IS
ALL THE WAY AT THE HANDS OF A
MEDICAL PERSONNEL. SUCH AN
IMPORTANT QUESTION. THANK YOU
FOR ASKING IT. WE WERE VERY
INTENTIONAL ABOUT MAKING SURE
THAT ALL LIABILITY WAS TAKEN
OUT. THE GOAL HERE IS NOT TO BE
MORE ONEROUS ON OUR RESTAURANTS
AND BARS. WE'RE HAVING ENOUGH OF
A TOUGH TIME THESE DAYS IN THIS
FINANCIAL CLIMATE. THE GOAL IS
SIMPLY TO MAKE SURE THAT WE ALL
HAVE A PLAN IN PLACE. WHEN THIS
HAPPENS, I GOT TO TELL YOU, LIKE
, AS, SOMEBODY IN THE BUSINESS,
THE LAST THING IN THE WORLD, WE
WANT IS OUR LOCATIONS. MANY OF
US WHO YOU KNOW, HAVE SAVED
LIFETIME SAVINGS TO GET THESE
PLACES OPEN, TO BE EVEN
INDIRECTLY FACILITATING SEXUAL
ASSAULT. IT'S INCREDULOUS.
ABSOLUTELY. SO WE ALL WANT A
SAFE ENVIRONMENTS BETTER FOR
BUSINESS IF WE HAVE A SAFER
ENVIRONMENT. SO IF EVERYBODY IS
ON THE SAME PLAN ON HOW WE DEAL
WITH THIS, WE THINK IT'LL REALLY
CREATE AWARENESS, CREATE
PREVENTION, CUT DOWN ON THE
PROBLEM. I AND I COMPLETELY
APPRECIATE ALL OF THAT. I JUST
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT IN THAT
IN LIGHT OF THAT AWARENESS AND
PURSUING, YOU KNOW, WELL INTO
ALL WELL INTENDED, WE DON'T
ACCIDENTALLY PUT IN SOMEONE'S,
PERSONAL LIVES UNDER THE RISK OF
BEING LIABLE FOR A LAWSUIT, FOR
NOT PURSUING OR NOT BEING QUICK
ENOUGH OR NOT BEING ATTENTIVE
ENOUGH OR, YOU KNOW, WHATEVER IT
MAY BE. IT'S A GREAT QUESTION
THAT WE THEY'RE PROTECTED. IT'S
A GREAT QUESTION. AND EVERY ONE
OF THESE BILLS LACKS LIABILITY.
EVEN THE TESTING THAT GOES INTO
EFFECT, THAT'S ALREADY LAW. NOW
ON JULY 1ST, THERE'S NO
LIABILITY ASSOCIATED WITH
POSITIVE TESTS. THE GOAL IS NOT.
THE GOAL IS TO HELP THESE
ESTABLISHMENTS, NOT THE OTHER
WAY AROUND. OKAY. THANK YOU.
SENATOR ALVARADO GIL. HI,
ASSEMBLYMEMBER. I JUST WANTED TO
ACKNOWLEDGE, THAT IN THIS
VERSION OF YOUR BILL THAT YOU
CORRECTLY, FOCUSED ON DRINK
SPIKING, WHICH IS ALL
ENCOMPASSING OF NOT JUST
ROHYPNOL, BUT OTHER DRUGS. SO I
ENCOURAGE YOU TO CONTINUE TO DO
THAT AS YOU PROMOTE THIS VERY
IMPORTANT TOPIC. THANK YOU. I'VE
GOT A QUESTION ACTUALLY RELATED
TO YOUR PRIOR BILL, BECAUSE I
THINK ALVARADO GIL MADE A GREAT
POINT THAT THERE'S A WHOLE ARRAY
OF DRUGS THAT ARE USED. NOW, DO
THOSE DRUG TESTING KITS, ARE
THEY ABLE TO DETERMINE ALL THESE
DRUGS THAT ARE USED OR, YOU
KNOW, THAT'S A GREAT QUESTION,
RIGHT NOW, THE ONES THERE'S AN
ARRAY OF DIFFERENT TYPES OF
TESTS AND SOME TESTS FOR
DIFFERENT TYPES OF DRUGS. SO WE
DON'T KNOW IF THEY'RE
COMPREHENSIVE. SO I'M ASSUMING
THIS IS GOING TO BE CONTINUE TO
BE A MOVING TARGET AS TECHNOLOGY
CHANGES AND PEOPLE TRY TO SKIRT
OKAY. AND PERFECT IS THE ENEMY
OF GOOD RIGHT. OH NO I'M I'M
FINE WITH IT. I WAS JUST CURIOUS
ON THAT BECAUSE WHEN SHE MADE
HER POINT, I GO, THAT'S A GOOD
POINT. SO YOU KNOW, YOU KNOW MR.
CHAIR, I THINK THE MOST POPULAR
TEST STRIP AVAILABLE OR TEST IS
A COASTER. AND I THINK THAT THE
ALCOHOL COMPANIES WILL BE
GETTING ON BOARD. IN FACT, I'M
SPEAKING TO SOME OF THEM RIGHT
NOW ABOUT SPONSORSHIP ASSOCIATED
WITH THIS TO PROVIDE THESE FREE
OF CHARGE, A COASTER THAT'S OUT,
INVISIBLE, THAT'S THAT EVERYONE
CAN SEE IF SOMEBODY HAS THAT ON
DISPLAY. I THINK A PERPETRATOR
IS GOING TO THINK TWICE ABOUT
SPIKING THAT PERSON'S DRINK. AND
THAT'S THE PLAN. THAT'S THE
GOAL. PREVENTION, NOT
NECESSARILY THE TEST ITSELF. NO,
I KNOW I'M WITH YOU ALL THE WAY.
IS THAT YOUR CLOTHES OR DO YOU
WANT TO CLOSE AGAIN,
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. OKAY. GREAT. THANK YOU
SIR. AND WE WILL TAKE THAT UP.
WE'RE NOT QUITE THERE. WE'RE
GETTING THERE. WHEN THE TIME
COMES. NOW WE'RE MOVING ON TO
FILE ITEM FIVE AB 2402. AND THE
RECOMMENDATION IS Dð PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS. AND
WITH THAT THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
THANK YOU VERY BRIEFLY, MR.
CHAIR. I WANT TO START BY
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE'S
THOUGHTFUL AMENDMENTS.
APPRECIATE THE EXCELLENT WORK ON
ALL OF THESE BILLS DONE IN THE
ANALYZES, PLEASED TO PRESENT AB
TWO 402, THE FINAL PIECE OF THIS
PACKAGE. I'LL BE PRESENTING
TODAY, AB TWO 402 REQUIRES THAT
THE DEPARTMENT OF ALCOHOL,
BEVERAGE CONTROL TO INCLUDE
TRAINING AROUND HOW TO PREVENT
CASES OF DRINK SPIKING INTO THE
EXISTING RESPONSIBLE BEVERAGE
SERVICE TRAININGS THAT ARE
OFFERED TO ALL ALCOHOL SERVING
STAFF MEMBERS OF RESTAURANTS,
BARS AND NIGHTCLUBS. ALL MY
EMPLOYEES HAVE TO GO THROUGH
THESE TRAININGS. THESE TRAININGS
WILL NOW INCLUDE THIS PIECE THAT
WOULD THAT HAS TO DO WITH
ROOFING, INCREASING THE TRAINING
OF EMPLOYEES AT THESE
INSTITUTIONS. A CRITICAL STEP IN
CURBING THE INCIDENCE OF
ROOFING, CREATING A SAFE AND
INCLUSIVE SOCIAL ENVIRONMENT. I
WANT TO NOTE THAT NO SINGLE
BILL, AS I STATED EARLIER, WILL
END DRINK SPIKING, SEXUAL
ASSAULT OR RAPE, BUT IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT WE KEEP ADDING TO
THE COMPREHENSIVE APPROACH IN
ADDRESSING THIS EPIDEMIC. KEEP
CHIPPING AWAY AT THIS TO BETTER
PROTECT THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA. VERY PLEASED TO BE
JOINED BY RAUL VERDUGO OF
ALCOHOL JUSTICE, WHO IS HERE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT. SIR, THIS
TIME YOU GET TWO MINUTES.
CONGRATULATIONS. THANK YOU, WE
SUPPORT AB 242402 AND APPLAUD
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LOWENTHAL'S
EFFORTS TO RAISE AWARENESS OF
THIS ONGOING EPIDEMIC AND AUTHOR
OF THE BILLS TO REDUCE ITS
OCCURRENCE BY INTRODUCING A
COMPREHENSIVE TRAINING PROGRAM.
A PRECEDENT CAN BE MADE TO MEET
BOTH THE ECONOMIC AND PUBLIC
HEALTH INTERESTS, ENSURING THAT
PATRONS FEEL NOT ONLY SAFE, BUT
REASSURED. THIS PROGRAM WILL
EQUIP PROPRIETORS WITH A
CONFIDENCE THAT THEIR STAFF CAN
ADEQUATELY MANAGE, PREVENT AND
REDUCE THE HARM THAT IMPACTS
BOTH MEN AND WOMEN. THESE CRIMES
ARE OFTEN UNREPORTED AND PROVE
VERY TRAUMATIZING FOR THE
VICTIMS. DESPITE THE LEVEL OF
VICTIMIZATIONS THAT OCCUR, WE
ASK THAT THE COMMITTEE SUPPORT
AB TWO 402. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SIR. THANK YOU, MATT ROBINSON,
ON BEHALF OF THE CITY OF WEST
HOLLYWOOD IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER METOO TESTIMONY IN
SUPPORT? SEEING NONE. ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION? SEEING NONE. PULL IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE.
QUESTIONS, COMMENTS, CONCERNS.
MOVING AT APPROPRIATE TIME.
SENATOR ARCHULETA THINKS IT'S A
GREAT BILL AND HE'S GOING TO
MOVE IT AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME.
BUT WE DO HAVE A QUESTION OR
COMMENT FROM SENATOR ALVARADO.
GIL, JUST FOR CONSISTENCY.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER, SO IN THIS
BILL, YOU MAKE A DEFINITION OF
DRINK SPIKING, WHICH INCLUDES,
PUTTING ALCOHOL OR DRUGS INTO
ANOTHER PERSON'S DRINK WITHOUT
THEIR KNOWLEDGE AND EXPRESS
CONSENT, ALSO KNOWN AS ROOFING.
ROOFING IS NOT A DEFINITION THAT
EQUATES DRINK SPIKING. SO I JUST
ENCOURAGE YOU, WITH THE INTENT
OF BEING EDUCATED IN HOW WE TALK
ABOUT DRUG SPIKING AND THE
CRIMES THAT CAN BE COMMITTED,
NOT TO, MISUSE THE TERMS,
WHETHER THEY'RE SLANG OR NOT.
THIS IS LEGISLATION. THIS WILL
STAY IN THE RECORD FOR LIFE. AND
I WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE
ACCURATE IN OUR DEFINITIONS. AND
SO TO BE EXPLICIT, THAT DRINK
SPIKING EQUATES ROOFING I THINK
IS INCORRECT. AND SO I ENCOURAGE
YOU TO CONTINUE TO MAKE THOSE
AMENDMENTS TO YOUR PACKAGE.
THANK YOU. APPRECIATE THAT.
SENATOR SEEING NO OTHER COMMENTS
OR QUESTIONS, YOU MAY CLOSE,
SIR, RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
VOTE. THANK YOU FOR THE THANK
YOU. THE DIALOG. DO WE HAVE ANY
MORE Ó HIDING BEHIND, MR.
MORLEY, COME ON UP. SO WE HAVE
ASSEMBLYMAN ZEBRA HERE. THAT
WOULD BE FILE ITEM 19, AB 3006,
AND HE'S LEAPFROGGING A TON OF
PEOPLE. SO THE RECOMMENDATION IS
Dð PASS, AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS. WITH THAT, THE
FLOOR IS YOURS, SIR. THANK YOU,
MR. CHAIR. MEMBERS, TODAY I'M
PROUD TO PRESENT AB 3006, WHICH
PROMOTES COLLABORATION AND
THOUGHTFUL PLANNING OF THE
STATE'S OFFSHORE WIND ECONOMY.
CALIFORNIA HAS SOME OF THE BEST
OFFSHORE WIND RESOURCES IN THE
COUNTRY THAT CAN PROVIDE CLEAN
ENERGY. AS THE SUN SETS, AND
WILL BE CRITICAL TO THE STATE'S
ABILITY TO MEET OUR CLEAN ENERGY
GOALS. OFFSHORE WIND ALSO HAS
THE POTENTIAL TO BRING A
SIGNIFICANT NUMBER OF HIGH
PAYING JOBS TO THE STATE,
ESPECIALLY IN COMMUNITIES
SURROUNDING THE STATE'S PORTS
AND SHIPPING HUBS. HOWEVER, THE
SHEER SCALE AND SIZE OF THE
TECHNOLOGY MEANS THAT THE STATE
WILL NEED TO BUILD SPECIALIZED
PORT FACILITIES IN A VERY SHORT
AMOUNT OF TIME. THE CALIFORNIA
ENERGY COMMISSION, IN ITS DRAFT
AB 525 OFFSHORE WIND STRATEGIC
PLAN, ESTIMATED THAT AT LEAST
$12 BILLION WILL BE NEEDED TO
UPGRADE EXISTING PORT
INFRASTRUCTURE WITH THOROUGH
PLANNING AND TIMELINE
ACCOUNTABILITY, CALIFORNIA CAN
BUILD THESE DEVELOPMENTS IN A
WAY THAT SUPPORTS A ROBUST
OFFSHORE WIND ECONOMY IN THE
STATE AND CREATES VALUABLE
MANUFACTURING AND ASSEMBLY JOBS
FOR MANY CALIFORNIANS, AB 3006
PRIORITIZES PLANNING FOR
OFFSHORE WIND DEVELOPMENT BY
INCLUDING AN EVALUATION OF
FUNDING NEEDS FOR OFFSHORE WIND
INFRASTRUCTURE IN THE GOVERNOR'S
FIVE YEAR INFRASTRUCTURE PLAN.
THIS BILL WILL HELP ENSURE THAT
THE INDUSTRY IS READY AND FUNDED
TO MEET OUR CLEAN ENERGY GOALS.
DESPITE ONGOING STATE BUDGET
CONSTRAINTS. WITH ME TODAY IS
BRIAN WHITE, REPRESENTING
OFFSHORE WIND CALIFORNIA, THE
SPONSOR OF THE BILL, TO PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL INFORMATION AND
ASSIST WITH QUESTIONS. THANK
YOU. WELCOME, MR. WHITE. YOU
HAVE TWO MINUTES. GREAT. I'LL BE
BRIEF WHENEVER YOU'RE READY.
THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR. MEMBERS
BRIAN WHITE WITH THE CALIFORNIA
OFFSHORE WIND. WE ARE THE
SPONSORS OF THE BILL. WE ALSO
REPRESENT TECHNOLOGY COMPANIES,
PORT REPRESENTATIVES,
ENGINEERING FIRMS WHO ARE
EXCITED ABOUT THIS OPPORTUNITY.
OUR SUPPORT FOR AB 3006 IS
SIMPLY BUILT ON THE FACT THAT
WITHOUT SIGNIFICANT PORT
CAPACITY TO UPGRADE THESE, THESE
FACILITIES, WE WILL NOT GET THIS
INDUSTRY STARTED. THE WEIGHT OF
THESE TURBINES ARE SIGNIFICANTLY
EXCESSIVE. THEY WILL SIMPLY
CRUSH AN EXISTING PORT. SO IN
ORDER TO DO THAT, WE HAVE TO
UPGRADE THESE PORTS FIRST. BUT
WE DON'T HAVE A PLAN TO GET
THERE. WE HAVE A PLAN THAT TELLS
US WE HAVE THESE LOFTY GOALS,
WHICH ARE IMPORTANT, BUT WE NEED
AN INFRASTRUCTURE PLAN AND A
FINANCING PLAN. SO THIS BILL,
ALL IT DOES IS, IS TELL THE
ADMINISTRATION DURING THE FIVE
YEAR INFRASTRUCTURE PLANNING
PROCESS, SIMPLY INCLUDE PORT
INFRASTRUCTURE PLANNING INTO
THAT PROCESS SO THAT WE KNOW
WHERE THE POTENTIAL FUNDING
COULD COME FROM. IT COULD COME
FROM PRIVATE DOLLARS, LOCAL
DOLLARS, FEDERAL DOLLARS. BUT IN
ORDER TO IN ORDER TO GET THERE,
WE HAVE TO HAVE A PLAN FIRST. SO
WITH THAT, MR. CHAIR, WE THANK
THE MEMBERS OF BR FOR AUTHORING
THIS BILL AND WE ASK FOR YOUR
VOTE. THANK YOU. CAN YOU STAY
FOR A SECOND? BECAUSE I'M
CHAIRING, SO I'M GOING TO DO
WHAT I WANT, SO IS THERE A
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN, THE OFFSHORE
WINDMILLS THAT THEY'RE USING,
LIKE OFF NANTUCKET IN
MASSACHUSETTS COMPARED? ARE THEY
GOING TO BE DIFFERENT THAN THE
ONES WE'RE USING ON THE WEST
COAST? SO TO ANSWER THAT
QUESTION, CHAIR, IS, YES, THE
OUR DIFFERENCES WE HAVE DEEP
WATERS IN CALIFORNIA. SO WE HAVE
TO HAVE FLOATING WIND
TECHNOLOGY. THEY WON'T BE GROUND
MOUNTED INTO THE FLOOR. AND LIKE
ON THE EAST COAST. SO IS THAT
WHAT ADDS TO THE WEIGHT. WELL
IT'S FOR THE PORTS. SO THE RIGHT
RIGHT. THESE TURBINES WILL BE
BIGGER THAN THE ONES THAT YOU
NORMALLY SEE. OKAY. GREAT THANKS
FOR SHARING THAT. YOU'RE
WELCOME. ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU
AGAIN MATT ROBINSON, ON BEHALF
OF THE PACIFIC MERCHANT SHIPPING
ASSOCIATION AND SUPPORT. THANK
YOU, SIR. MIKE MONAHAN FOR STATE
BUILDING TRADES AND SUPPORT
EARNING HIS PAY TODAY. GOOD JOB.
DAN, ON BEHALF OF THE PORT OF
LONG BEACH IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
. ALL RIGHT. ANYONE HERE IN
OPPOSITION SEEING NONE COME BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE. AND WE'RE
LOSING MEMBERS NOW. NOTHING.
WELL, WE DO. SO WE HAVE A
SUBCOMMITTEE. IT'S SOMEBODY. ARE
YOU GOING TO OFFER TO MAKE A
MOTION WHEN THE TIME IS RIGHT?
IT'S APPROPRIATE. OKAY, GREAT.
WITH THAT, YOU MAY CLOSE, SO THE
ONLY THING THAT I'LL ADD IS IN
ADDITION TO THE WEIGHT, IT'S
ALSO ABOUT THE SIZE OF THESE
THINGS, LIKE ONE OF THE WIND
TURBINES, WHICH LOOK A LOT LIKE
THE ONES YOU SEE WHEN YOU'RE
DRIVING OUT TO PALM SPRINGS.
THEY'RE SO LARGE THAT LIKE THE
THAT THE, THE ARMS OF THE
TURBINE WOULD NOT FIT INTO
DODGER STADIUM OR GIANT STADIUM.
SO YOU ALSO NEED ALL THIS
ADDITIONAL LAYDOWN SPACE. SO
THAT'S WHY WE NEED THE PORT
INFRASTRUCTURE, WHY IT'S GOING
TO COST SO MUCH. SO I'M
SUPPORTIVE OF THE BILL. I WAS
JUST I WAS JUST I WAS JUST
CURIOUS ON THE DIFFERENCE. AND I
DO BELIEVE YOU SAID IN YOUR
OPENING COMMENTS THAT YOU YOU
ACCEPT THE AMENDMENTS, CORRECT?
YES, YES. WE THOUGHT UNANIMOUS.
YES. AND SO THANK YOU. WITH
THAT, I RESPECTFULLY ASKED FOR
YOUR I VOTE AT THE APPROPRIATE.
YOU HAVE A MOTION. I'M
SUPPORTIVE AS WELL. SO GOOD
BILL, THANK YOU SO MUCH. NOW WE
HAVE A BUNCH OF AUTHORS HERE. SO
WHO'S NEXT? PHILIP. WHAT ITEM
NUMBER OKAY. MOVING ON TO FILE
ITEM NUMBER EIGHT AB 1635 BY THE
ASSEMBLYMAN FROM SAN DIEGO. AND
THE RECOMMENDATION IS Dð PASS TO
ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY COMMITTEE.
OH, NO, THAT'S GRAYSON. I ALWAYS
GET YOU GUYS CONFUSED BY ITEM
EIGHT. AB 1635 DO PASS AS
AMENDED, TO APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE. LOVE THAT,
RECOMMENDATION. THANK YOU, MR.
CHAIR. AND MEMBERS, PLEASURE TO
BE HERE WITH YOU THIS MORNING.
AND THIS IS A SAN DIEGO BILL, I
WANT TO THANK YOU AND COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR WORKING WITH ME ON
THIS BILL AND WOULD LIKE TO
ACCEPT THE PROPOSED AMENDMENTS
OUTLINED IN YOUR ANALYSIS ON
PAGE SIX AND SEVEN, AS PROPOSED
UNDER THE AMENDMENTS, AB 1635
WOULD REQUIRE THE DEPARTMENT OF
GENERAL SERVICES, IN
COORDINATION WITH THE DMV, TO
ENTER INTO NEGOTIATIONS TO LEASE
PROPERTY LOCATED IN THE
HILLCREST NEIGHBORHOOD OF SAN
DIEGO TO ENSURE THAT IT CAN BE
USED FOR THE DEVELOPMENT OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND MAXIMIZE
REDEVELOPMENT POTENTIAL ON THE
SITE BY 2026. IN 2007, SO ALMOST
20 YEARS AGO, SB 754 WAS ENACTED
TO AUTHORIZE DGS TO LEASE THE
HILLCREST DMV PROPERTY SITE FOR
REDEVELOPMENT OF MIXED USE AND
PRIVATE USE OF THE FACILITIES.
BUT UNFORTUNATELY, NO AGREEMENTS
HAVE BEEN EXECUTED AT THE SITE
AND THE PROPERTY CONTINUES TO BE
IN NEED OF REPLACEMENT, SO THIS
WILL BEGIN THE STEPS TOWARDS
DIRECTION FOR A SITE PROGRAM.
VISION WHICH WILL MAXIMIZE
HOUSING OUTCOMES AND ACCELERATE
A TIMELINE TO COMPLETE. WHAT IS
BECOMING A HOLE IN THE
REVITALIZATION OF THE
SURROUNDING NEIGHBORHOOD WITH
SHARED STATE AND LOCAL GOALS.
MET HERE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT.
I HAVE HOLLY FOR MANY ON BEHALF
OF THE SAN DIEGO HOUSING
COMMISSION AND MOYAMOYA ON
BEHALF OF THE CITY OF SAN DIEGO,
WELCOME. THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR.
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE, HOLLY,
FOR MEETING ON BEHALF OF THE SAN
DIEGO HOUSING COMMISSION'S
PRESIDENT AND CEO, LISA JONES.
AND WE WANT TO THANK THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FOR CONTINUING
TO CREATE SOME CREATIVE
SOLUTIONS AND INNOVATIVE WAYS OF
TRYING TO MAXIMIZE UNDERUTILIZED
GOVERNMENT PROPERTIES, TO TRY TO
USE FOR MORE, TO BUILD MORE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING. OUR REGION
IS NOT ALONE IN FACING A
CONTINUED AFFORDABILITY CRISIS
AND HOMELESSNESS CRISIS, BUT THE
STATE NEEDS TO BE LOOKING AT OUR
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS, LOOKING AT
MORE THAN JUST SURPLUS LANDS,
BUT THOSE LANDS THAT ARE TRULY
UNDERUTILIZED TO TRY TO CREATE
MORE OF THESE CREATIVE SOLUTIONS
TO ADDRESS THE CRISIS. SO AGAIN,
THANK YOU, MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE, WE URGE YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. WELL DONE.
WELCOME. THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR
AND MEMBERS. I'M MOIRA TOP HERE
ON BEHALF OF THE CITY OF SAN
DIEGO, ALSO A CO-SPONSOR OF THE
MEASURE. SAN DIEGO, DATING BACK
TO THEN COUNCIL MEMBER WARD DAYS
HAS BEEN A LEADER IN IN HOUSING
AFFORDABILITY ORDINANCES TO
EXPAND, ALL OF THE OPPORTUNITIES
FOR, HOUSING AT ALL INCOME
LEVELS, AND A BILL LIKE THIS IS
REALLY IMPORTANT BECAUSE IT WILL
ENABLE THOSE REFORMS THAT WE'VE
DONE AT THE LOCAL LEVEL TO
REALLY COME TO FRUITION, THE DMV
SITE AT HILLCREST IS A PERFECT
SITE TO REALLY MARRY THE STATE
AND LOCAL PARTNERSHIP TO BUILD
HOUSING IN OUR URBAN URBAN CORE.
VERY MUCH APPRECIATE NOW
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WARDS, INTEREST
IN DOING THIS AND HELP TO GET
THIS ACROSS THE FINISH LINE AND
WE APPRECIATE IT. AND I ASK FOR
YOUR VOTE. THANK YOU. WE
APPRECIATE YOUR TESTIMONY. DO WE
HAVE ANY MEAT TO TESTIMONY IN
THE HOUSE? WE DO. COME FORWARD,
SIR. YES. ONE ME TWO. IN SUPPORT
FOR MARK STIVERS WITH THE
CALIFORNIA HOUSING PARTNERSHIP.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
ANYONE IN THE ROOM IN OPPOSITION
SEEING NONE PULL IT BACK TO OUR
EVER DWINDLING COMMITTEE. OUR
LARGE COMMITTEE. GO AHEAD.
SENATOR OUR QUESTION, ASSEMBLY
MEMBER, WHAT ARE THE PLANS FOR
THE SITE? I KNOW WE'RE HERE IN
CALIFORNIA. WE'RE TRYING TO
BUILD AS MUCH AS WE CAN, BUT
WHAT'S WHAT DO WE HAVE ON THE
PAPER? SO THERE'S CURRENTLY NO
PLANS FOR THE SITE. AND THAT'S
WHAT'S BEEN FRUSTRATING, IS THAT
20 YEARS AGO THROUGH THEN,
SENATOR KEHOE, ONE OF MY
PREDECESSORS, AUTHORIZING
LEGISLATION, WE COULD HAVE PUT
SOMETHING IN MOTION, BUT THERE
JUST DOESN'T SEEM TO BE ANY REAL
IMPETUS OR URGENCY FOR, STATE
LEADERS TO BE ABLE TO FIGURE OUT
WHAT THEY WANT TO DO WITH THIS.
AND IT'S JUST BEEN, JUST HANGING
OUT THERE. AND SO I WAS USING
THIS OPPORTUNITY, AS WE DO FOR
AS REPRESENTATIVES OF OUR
DISTRICT, TO REALLY ONE PROVIDE
SOME OF THE INITIAL COMMUNITY
OUTREACH BECAUSE THE COMMUNITY
HAS GROWN UP A LITTLE BIT OVER
THE LAST 20 YEARS, IT AROUND
THERE HAS A REAL GOOD FOCUS
PLAN, DEVELOPMENT OF WHAT IT
WANTS TO BECOME. BUT YOU GOT
THIS DONUT HOLE YOU GOT THIS
STATE PROPERTY RIGHT IN THE
MIDDLE OF IT, WHERE WE DO STILL
NEED TO HAVE A DMV FACILITY IN
THERE. THERE'S NO OTHER AREA
THAT SORT OF MAKES SENSE IN THE
GENERAL, PART OF THE CITY THERE,
BUT AS WE'RE SEEING AS AN
EXAMPLE IN SAN FRANCISCO RIGHT
NOW, POTENTIALLY SUCCESSFUL
REDEVELOPMENT THERE ON THAT
PROPERTY THAT CAN ACTUALLY BE
MIXED USE, NOT JUST A DMV
FACILITY, BUT MAYBE HOUSING
ABOVE IT. YOU HAVE AN URBANIZED
ENVIRONMENT. AND SO WE NEED TO
BE A LITTLE BIT MORE THOUGHTFUL
AND CONGRUENT WITH THE
SURROUNDING AREA. AND THE CITY,
MEANWHILE, IS BEING IS PUTTING
IN A MAJOR INVESTMENT FOR A
LINEAR PARK NEXT DOOR TO AN
ADJACENT TO THIS SITE. AND SO
THE IDEA THAT WE CAN MAYBE
INCORPORATE AND THREAD IN SOME
PUBLIC SPACE, ARE ALL GOOD
ELEMENTS OF WHAT WE COULD DO.
THIS BILL CATALYZES, I THINK,
THE VISION THAT WE WANT TO BE
ABLE TO SEE AND REALLY ASK AND
IF WE ARE SUCCESSFUL AND GET TO
THE GOVERNOR'S DESK REALLY
DIRECTS THEM, TO START
IMPLEMENTING A VISION. ALL
RIGHT. WELL, GOOD LUCK TO SAN
DIEGO. THANK YOU. MOVE IT AT AN
APPROPRIATE TIME. RIGHT JUST MY
FINAL COMMENT BEFORE YOU CLOSE
IS WE'RE NOT GOING TO HIT OUR
HOUSING GOALS IF WE'RE NOT
DOING, URBAN INFILL. AND IT
SOUNDS LIKE THIS COULD
POTENTIALLY BE A FANTASTIC
PROJECT THAT BENEFITS THE WHOLE
HILLCREST COMMUNITY. SO I WILL
BE SUPPORTIVE WHEN THE TIME
COMES. AND WAY OVER. YOU
SHOULDN'T SIT SO FAR AWAY FROM
ME. I WAS, AND THERE WAS
SOMEBODY IN BETWEEN US BEFORE,
BUT THEY TEMPORARILY JUST LEFT
TEMPORARILY, SO I WASN'T THAT
FAR FROM YOU. THANK YOU. SORRY
ABOUT THAT. TO INTERRUPT YOUR
YOUR TRAIN OF THOUGHT. AND YOU
DIDN'T DO ANYTHING. SO Þ, SO I
DO HAVE A QUESTION. MEMBER WARD.
SO IS THIS A LEASE FOR THE LAND
OR FOR THE BUILDING? FOR THE
LAND? SO IT AUTHORIZES THE
ABILITY FOR THEM TO BE ABLE TO
ENTER INTO A LEASE AGREEMENT.
ALL THESE, OF COURSE, ARE, YOU
KNOW, UP FOR FUTURE NEGOTIATION
AND FUTURE LEASE. NEGOTIATIONS
BUT THAT'S, THAT'S THE UPDATED
AUTHORIZATION THAT THIS BILL
WOULD DO, ON TOP OF THE EXISTING
LAW, WHICH IS SB 754. OKAY. SO
THE QUESTION, THAT FOLLOWS THAT
THROUGH IS IT'S MY UNDERSTANDING
THAT THIS PROPERTY DOES NOT HAVE
A SURPLUS DESIGNATION AS OF
RIGHT NOW. IS THAT CORRECT?
THAT'S CORRECT. AND IT WOULDN'T
AND IT SHOULDN'T BECAUSE WE NEED
THAT DMV FACILITY. RIGHT SO IT'S
BUT WE DON'T NEED IS A
STANDALONE BUILDING WITH 80% OF
THE FOOT BEING A PARKING LOT.
RIGHT THERE IS SOMETHING THAT
YOU CAN DO A LITTLE BIT MORE
CREATIVELY THAT CAN MEET ALL THE
PROGRAMMATIC NEEDS, INCLUDING
PARKING FOR THAT, THAT LOCATION.
AND SO THIS BILL REALLY UPDATES
AND AUTHORIZES YOU KNOW, A MORE
CREATIVE. BUT FITTING PROGRAM
DEVELOPMENT FOR THAT SITE. OKAY,
AND THEN, OKAY, SO THE VISION IS
TO ALLOW THIS BILL TO MOVE
FORWARD SO THAT YOU CAN LEASE
THE PLANT WITHOUT HAVING THE
DESIGNATION OF SURPLUS IN ORDER
TO BE ABLE TO USE THE PARKING
LOT LAND, PER SE, FOR BUILDING
ADDITIONAL STRUCTURES IN THERE.
THAT'S ACCURATE. OKAY. ALL
RIGHT. THANK YOU. I SAID MY BIT.
SO YOU YOU MAY CLOSE. THANK YOU.
WELL, I APPRECIATE AND AGREE
FULLY. I THINK KIND OF WITH YOUR
ASSESSMENT, I WOULD JUST ALSO
CHARACTERIZE THIS AS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO REALLY THINK MORE
BROADLY ABOUT OUR STATE LANDS
THAT MAKE A LOT OF SENSE FOR
HOUSING OPPORTUNITIES. THIS IS
JUST ONE SITE, AND IT'S AN
IMPORTANT SITE THAT WOULD BE
CONSISTENT WITH THE VISION THAT
WE HAVE FOR THE SURROUNDING
COMMUNITY, BUT LET'S ALSO TAKE
THIS AS A MAYBE AN OPPORTUNITY
TO REFLECT ON OUR OWN
BUREAUCRATIC OBSTACLES THAT ARE
SORT OF SELF-IMPOSED THAT, THAT,
THAT REALLY REQUIRE US TO BE
ABLE TO DO MORE WITH STATE
LANDS. AND WITH THAT, I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
THANK YOU, SIR, AND WE WILL TAKE
THAT UP. WE HAVE A MOTION FROM
SENATOR ARCHULETA WHEN THE TIME
COMES. SO THANK YOU. MOVING ON.
I'M ALSO HERE TO PRESENT. OH, I
DIDN'T KNOW THAT. THAT'S ALL
RIGHT, SO I'M HAPPY TO TELL YOU.
NO, IT'S NOT FOR GRAYSON. WHO'S
IT FOR? IT'S, AB 2032. IT'S FOR
ME. OH, YEAH? YOU HAD TWO BILLS.
I HAVE TWO BILLS.
CONGRATULATIONS. AND THIS IS
NUMBER I GOT TWO. I ONLY GOT TWO
BILLS OVER ON THE ASSEMBLY SIDE.
WELL, THIS ONE WILL HOPEFULLY
ALSO WILL BE A REAL. THAT'S NOT
TRUE. BY THE WAY, I DID A LITTLE
BIT BETTER THAN THAT OKAY. SO
LET'S GO. SO IT IS FILE ITEM
NINE AB 2832 BY ASSEMBLYMAN WARD
WITH THE RECOMMENDATION OF Dð
PASS BY APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE. AND WITH THAT FLOOR
IS YOURS. THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR.
AND MEMBERS, AGAIN, AB 2032 WILL
ENABLE THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OF
BUSINESS AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT AND THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF FOOD AND
AGRICULTURE TO TAKE OWNERSHIP OF
CONTRACTING WITH INTERNATIONAL
ENTITIES IN SUPPORT OF
CALIFORNIA'S SMALL BUSINESS DUE
TO THE STATE'S RESTRICTIONS ON
PAYMENT AND CONTRACTING, BOTH
DEPARTMENTS MUST RELY ON THIRD
PARTY FIDUCIARIES WHEN HANDLING
CONTRACTS WITH TRADE SHOW
ORGANIZERS PAYING VIA WIRE
TRANSFER, CREDIT CARD OR FOREIGN
CURRENCY, ALL OF WHICH ARE
STANDARD AND EXPECTED PAYMENT
FOR TRADE SHOW ORGANIZERS. THESE
RESTRICTIONS ADD CURRENTLY
FINANCIAL COSTS AND LIMIT BOTH
FLEXIBILITY AND AUTONOMY WHEN
CONDUCTING BUSINESS WITH
INTERNATIONAL ENTITIES. THIS
BILL PROVIDES CONTRACT CODE
EXEMPTIONS TO ALLOW BOTH
DEPARTMENTS TO ENTER INTO
CONTRACTING AND PROCUREMENT
AGREEMENTS FOR INTERNATIONAL
AFFAIRS. THIS WILL BE A MUCH
NEEDED CHANGE, WILL MAKE IT MORE
EFFICIENT TO UTILIZE EXISTING
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT AND TRADE
PROMOTION ACCOUNTS AND SPECIFY
GRANT FUNDS IN FOR THE BENEFIT
OF SUPPORTING CALIFORNIA
EXPORTERS. THERE ARE NO
WITNESSES IN IN SUPPORT OR IN
PRIMARY OPPOSITION, I BELIEVE.
AND WITH THAT, I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I VOTE
WHEN YOU HAVE A RIGHTEOUS BILL,
YOU DON'T NEED WITNESSES. IS
THERE ANY ME TIÂU TESTIMONY,
TESTIMONY AND SUPPORT SEEING
NONE ANY TESTIMONY IN OPPOSITION
? SEEING NONE. ASSEMBLYMAN WAS
CORRECT. PULL IT BACK TO OUR
COMMITTEE, SENATOR BOGUE. I'M
GOOD. THEY'RE GOOD. SENATOR
ARCHULETA, YOU WANT TO SAY IT'S
A GREAT BILL? YEP IT'S A GREAT
BILL. AND I'LL MOVE TO MOVE IT
AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME. ONE
QUICK QUESTION. THIS WILL
OBVIOUSLY EXPEDITE THE SITUATION
BECAUSE WE'RE TRYING TO BRING IN
BUSINESS AND ENHANCE OUR
ECONOMY. SO I'M ASSUMING IT'S
GOING TO OPEN UP SOME DOORS. WE
ARE TRYING TO SELL CALIFORNIA
AND WE'RE TRYING TO PLAY BIGGER
ON A BIGGER STAGE. BUT OUR OWN
AGAIN, KIND OF BUREAUCRACY,
BUREAUCRATIC, REGULATIONS ARE
NOT CONSISTENT WITH HOW WE DO
BUSINESS WHEN WE ARE OPERATING
INTERNATIONALLY RIGHT NOW.
THAT'S WHAT THIS BILL IS ABOUT.
MOVE IT AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME.
GREAT. WONDERFUL. BILL WILL BE
SUPPORTIVE. AND YOU MAY CLOSE. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR. AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU SIR. OKAY WE GO
IN FILE ORDER. DO WE ONLY HAVE
ONE AUTHOR HERE AT THIS POINT?
AND SO, SENATOR AGUIAR-CURRY,
PLEASE COME UP AND YOU HAVE Þ
FILE ITEM TEN IS ON CONSENT. SO
YOU'LL BE PRESENTING FILE ITEM
11 AB 2237 WITH THE
RECOMMENDATION OF Dð PASS AS
AMENDED, TO APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE. AND WITH THAT, YOU
MAY BEGIN. THANK YOU, MR.
CHAIRMAN. SENATORS FIRST, I
WOULD LIKE TO THANK YOU AND THE
HEALTH NGO COMMITTEE STAFF FOR
THE WORK WITH OUR OFFICE. I WILL
ACCEPT THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS
TODAY. CALIFORNIA'S YOUTH ARE
FACING A MENTAL HEALTH CRISIS
SINCE 2017. RATES OF ANXIETY AND
DEPRESSION AMONG CALIFORNIA'S
CHILDREN HAVE SHOT UP 70, AND
ONE THIRD OF CALIFORNIA'S
ADOLESCENTS EXPERIENCE SERIOUS
PSYCHOLOGICAL DISTRESS BETWEEN
2019 AND 2021, INCLUDING A 20%
INCREASE IN ADOLESCENT SUICIDE
RATES. MANY FAMILIES STRUGGLE TO
FIND AFFORDABLE MENTAL HEALTH
FOR THEIR CHILDREN. SPECIALTY
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES PROVIDED
BY COUNTY MENTAL HEALTH PLANS
PROVIDE A KEY LIFELINE FOR OVER
243,000 YOUTH ACROSS CALIFORNIA
IN ORDER TO RECEIVE THESE
SERVICES, YOUTH UNDER 21 MUST
HAVE A CONDITIONAL EXCUSE ME, A
CONDITION PLACING THEM AT HIGH
RISK FOR A MENTAL HEALTH
DISORDER, HAVE A SIGNIFICANT
IMPAIRMENT AND MENTAL HEALTH
DISORDER, OR SIGNIFICANT TRAUMA
LIKE SEXUAL ASSAULT. HOWEVER,
WHEN A YOUTH MOVES FROM COUNTY
TO COUNTY, THEIR MENTAL HEALTH
CARE IS HALTED WHILE THEY
REESTABLISH ELIGIBILITY, IT'S
HALTED. CAN YOU IMAGINE WHAT
THEY HAVE TO GET? ELIGIBILITY
FROM THE OTHER COUNTY? THIS
RESULTS IN GAPS IN MENTAL HEALTH
CARE THAT CAN BURDEN FAMILIES
AND RISK MINORS ENTERING THE
FOSTER CARE SYSTEM. THIS BILL
SUPPORTS FAMILIES BY
STREAMLINING ELIGIBILITY ACROSS
COUNTY LINES FOR HIGH RISK YOUTH
WHO QUALIFY FOR SPECIALTY MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES, AB 2237 WOULD
REQUIRE THAT DCS ISSUE
GUIDELINES TO SUPPORT COUNTIES,
COORDINATE AND EXPEDIATE THE
TRANSFER OF SPECIALTY MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES FROM ONE COUNTY
TO ANOTHER. THIS BILL WILL HELP
EMPOWER FAMILIES WHO DON'T KNOW
HOW TO NAVIGATE COMPLICATED
SOCIAL SERVICES SO THAT THEIR
YOUTHS CAN. CONTINUITY OF CARE
IS PRESERVED. TODAY I HAVE
RICHARD DAVIS. I BELIEVE. THERE
HE IS, RICHARD DAVIS POLICY AND
LEGISLATIVE AFFAIRS MANAGER AT
THE CALIFORNIA COUNCIL OF
COMMUNITY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
AGENCIES. THANK YOU SIR. YOU'RE
IN THE BACK ROW. ONLY BAD KIDS
SIT IN THE BACK ROW. AND THE
NEXT TIME, IF YOU'RE GOING TO DO
THAT, LET ME KNOW. WE'LL PLAY
WALKUP MUSIC FOR YOU. WALK UP.
OH, SO I CAN HAVE AN ENTRANCE?
YEAH, YEAH, I APPRECIATE IT.
THANK YOU. ANYWAY, TWO MINUTES,
SIR. I APPRECIATE IT. THANK YOU,
MY NAME IS RICHARDSON DAVIS WITH
THE CALIFORNIA COUNCIL OF
COMMUNITY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
HEALTH AGENCIES, A PROUD SPONSOR
OF TODAY'S BILL, SO CALIFORNIA'S
FOSTER YOUTH, AS THE MEMBER
SAID, ARE EXPERIENCING A HEALTH
CRISIS, MENTAL HEALTH CRISIS
SINCE 2017. SO SPECIFICALLY WHEN
A MINOR IS RECEIVING SPECIALTY
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES IN ONE
COUNTY AND MOVED TO A DIFFERENT
COUNTY OR A NEW COUNTY, THEY
MUST PROVIDE THE CONTINUED
SPECIALTY MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
WHILE THEY CONDUCT A REQUIRED
INVESTIGATION FOR THE TRANSFER
PROCESS. SO THIS BILL WILL
PRESERVE COUNTIES AND THE
ABILITY TO CONDUCT APPROPRIATE
REVIEWS WITH MEETING THE
CHANGING MENTAL HEALTH NEEDS AND
CONDITIONS, WHILE ALSO ENSURING
THE CONTINUITY OF CARE FOR YOUTH
, I'LL KEEP IT SHORT TODAY, SO
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. AND WE ASK
FOR YOUR VOTE. THANK YOU SIR.
WELL DONE. APPRECIATE IT. ANY
OTHER? ME TOO. TESTIMONY AND
SUPPORT. SEEING NONE. OH ANOTHER
SUPPORT. NO WALK UP MUSIC FOR
YOU EITHER. BUT YOU WERE OUT OF
THE ROOM SO CLIFTON WILSON, ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA ACADEMY
OF CHILD AND ADOLESCENT
PSYCHIATRY IN SUPPORT, THANK
YOU. AND THEY NEED TO CHANGE
THAT NAME. THAT'S TOO LONG. ALL
RIGHT. ANYBODY IN OPPOSITION
SEEING NONE PULL IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE. QUESTIONS, COMMENTS,
CONCERNS. YES. MY WINGMAN,
SENATOR ARCHULETA. YES BUT MY
CONCERN, OF COURSE, IS THE
MENTAL SITUATION HERE. BUT HOW
ABOUT PHYSICAL GOING FROM ONE
COUNTY TO THE OTHER AND THE
EXPENDITURES, TO KEEP THAT CHILD
HEALTHY AND SAFE AND, AND THEN
MAYBE THE OTHER COUNTY MAY NOT
BE ABLE TO BE READY. IS THIS
BILL GOING TO BE ABLE TO MOVE
THAT FINANCIAL BURDEN? WELL THE
GUY THE GUIDELINES HERE IS THAT
DCFS WILL ISSUE GUIDANCE TO
SUPPORT THE COUNTIES TO HELP
EXPEDIATE IT. YOU KNOW, THERE'S
NOTHING MORE HEARTBREAKING TO ME
IS THAT A YOUNG PERSON UNDER THE
AGE OF 21 IS MOVING FROM PLACE
TO PLACE, AND CAN'T CONTINUE
THAT HEALTH CARE IN A TIME WHEN
WE'RE TRYING TO GET PEOPLE OFF
THE STREET? AND CAN YOU IMAGINE
WAITING TO GET CARE FOR SIX
MONTHS OR MORE FROM MOVING FROM
COUNTY TO COUNTY? SO IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT THAT I MAKE SURE THAT
WE HAVE THE CONTINUUM OF CARE
FOR THESE YOUNG PEOPLE. AND, I
REALLY THINK THAT THIS IS A
REALLY VIABLE BILL. I WAS
SHOCKED THAT THIS WASN'T DONE
ALREADY, AND IT WAS BROUGHT TO
THE ATTENTION OF ONE OF ONE OF
MY, MY, MY FELLOW. AND I THINK
THIS WAS INCREDIBLE POLICY THAT
WE'RE WORKING ON. WOULD IT
ELIMINATE THAT SIX MONTH PERIOD
OF TIME AS AN EXAMPLE, WOULD IT
EXPEDITE IT DOWN? WE WANT THREE
MONTHS, OR THE GOAL IS TO
EXPEDITE IT, AND IT'S GOING TO
TAKE SOME TIME BECAUSE AS WE
CHANGE ANYTHING WITH ANY OF OUR
AGENCIES, IT'S GOING TO TAKE
SOME TIME. BUT THE TIME IS NOW
TO START MAKING THOSE MOVES.
VERY GOOD. OKAY. I THINK WITH I
THINK WITH COVID, MANY PEOPLE
HAVE HAVE HAD MENTAL HEALTH
ISSUES, BUT ONE OUT OF EVERY
THREE FOSTER YOUTH IN L.A.
COUNTY RESIDES IN MY DISTRICT.
AND ME AND ASSEMBLYMAN LACKEY,
ON A REGULAR BASIS, MEET WITH
FOSTER YOUTH AND BUYING PIZZA
AND JUST LISTEN TO THEIR
STORIES. I THINK THEY'RE MORE
ISOLATED THAN THAN MOST TEENS
ARE JUST BY VIRTUE OF THEIR
SITUATION. SO THIS IS MUCH
NEEDED AND SHOULD HAVE BEEN DONE
MUCH EARLIER. AND I WILL BE
SUPPORTIVE OF THE BILL AS WELL.
AND WITH THAT, YOU MAY CLOSE. I
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. LET US
ALL HELP THE YOUNG FOSTER
CHILDREN THAT NEED THIS KIND OF
CONTINUAL HELP. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU Ó. THAT WOULD BE AN AYE
VOTE. YES AND OUR FEARLESS
LEADERS, I'M GOING TO PRESENT
TO. YOU'RE STILL. OH, I'M STILL
OKAY. I'M STILL FEARLESS LEADER.
OKAY, GOOD I LIKE THAT. AND WHAT
ARE WE? WHAT ARE YOU PRESENTING?
OH. OH YEAH. THE COMMITTEE BILL.
OKAY GOOD. AND THEN THE OTHER
ONE. OKAY OKAY. UP NEXT FILE
ITEM 1AB 1768. THIS IS THE
ASSEMBLY COMMITTEES COMMITTEE.
BILL AND WITH THAT, MR. CHAIR,
THE FLOOR IS YOURS. RECENT
AMENDMENTS TO AB 1768 WERE PUT
FORTH BY THE CALIFORNIA HORSE
RACING BOARD TO ADDRESS SEVERAL
OUT OF DATE CODE SECTIONS IN
LAW. THE COMMITTEE BILL NOW
ALIGNS THE CALIFORNIA HORSE
RACING LAW AND THE GENERAL
REGULATORY ACTIVITIES OF THE
NEWLY ESTABLISHED FEDERAL HORSE
RACING INTEGRITY AND SAFETY
AUTHORITY. THAT'S ANOTHER WAY
TOO LONG. WHAT I DON'T EVEN KNOW
IF THEY HAVE AN ACRONYM, THE OH,
THEY DO THIS NEW ORGANIZATION.
NO, THEY DON'T. ALONG WITH THE
CHRB IS CHARGED WITH ENFORCING
THE UNIFORM SAFETY AND INTEGRITY
RULES FOR THOROUGHBRED RACING. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
ON THIS IMPORTANT LEGISLATION.
DO YOU HAVE ANY DO YOU HAVE ANY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT? NO. ANYONE
IN THE ROOM THAT WANTS TO CURRY
FAVOR WITH THE CHAIR AND DO A ME
TOO? NO. SEEING NONE. ANYBODY IN
OPPOSITION? SEEING NONE. PULL IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE. MOVE IT
AT AN APPROPRIATE TIME. I DIDN'T
SEE ANYBODY WRITE IN. SO LET'S
GO AHEAD AND MOVE IT. I, I DO
WANT TO SAY YOU DID SAY YOU'RE
GOING TO TAKE, ACCEPT THE, THE
AMENDMENTS AND THIS. NO NO. OH,
I MISREAD IT. SO IT'S TO RETURN
THIS BILL BACK TO THE SENATE
FLOOR. OKAY, GOOD. YES ANYONE
DOWN HERE? GOING, GOING. GONE.
OKAY, SO YOU MAY CLOSE,
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR. AYE
VOTE WHEN THE APPROPRIATE TIME
COMES. AND WHO KNOWS WHEN THAT
WILL BE? OKAY. WE ARE NOW MOVING
TO. IT'S A BUSY DAY TODAY, SO
I'M NOT FAULTING ANYBODY.
THERE'S A LOT GOING ON. OKAY.
NOW WE'RE MOVING TO FILE ITEM 17
WHICH IS ASSEMBLYMAN GIBSON.
IT'S HIS BIRTHDAY TODAY. IS THAT
WHY HE'S NOT HERE? AND THE
RECOMMENDATION IS Dð PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE. AND
WITH THAT, SIR, THE FLOOR IS
YOURS. THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR. AND
MEMBERS, I WILL BE PRESENTING.
I'M PRESENTING 2816 ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GIBSON, WHICH
SEEKS TO ESTABLISH SCHOOL
MAPPING TECHNOLOGY FOR FIRST
RESPONDERS ON K-12 CAMPUSES.
SCHOOL MAPPING TECHNOLOGY WOULD
ALLOW EMERGENCY RESPONDERS TO
HAVE ACCESS TO A SCHOOL'S LAYOUT
PRIOR TO ENTERING THE CAMPUS. IN
2023, THERE WAS A REPORTED 346
SCHOOL SHOOTINGS INCIDENTS
ACROSS THE US, INJURING ABOUT
191 STUDENTS IN CALIFORNIA,
THERE HAVE BEEN 96 SCHOOL
SHOOTING INCIDENTS WITHIN THE
LAST FIVE YEARS, RESULTING IN 82
PEOPLE BEING WOUNDED OR KILLED.
IT IS VITAL THAT WE ARE
SUPPLYING OUR FIRST RESPONDERS
WITH THE MOST ADVANCED SECURITY
SYSTEMS THAT WILL NOT ONLY
DECREASE EMERGENCY RESPONSE
TIMES, BUT REEMPHASIZE THE
IMPORTANCE OF STUDENT SAFETY. AB
2816 HAS ENJOYED BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT AND HAS RECEIVED NO NO
VOTES WITH ME TODAY IS JOE
HANSEN WITH THE CRITICAL
RESPONSE GROUP TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF THE MEASURE. OKAY,
MR. HANSEN, YOU HAVE TWO
MINUTES, SIR. THANK YOU, MR.
CHAIRMAN. AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE, AS I SAID, MY NAME IS
JOE HANSEN. I WANT TO THANK THE
AUTHOR, MR. GIBSON, AND HIS
STAFF, AS WELL AS THE STAFF OF
THE COMMITTEE FOR ALLOWING US TO
BRING THIS FORWARD TODAY, A
LITTLE ABOUT MY BACKGROUND. I
CAME FROM THE SPECIAL OPERATIONS
COMMUNITY, SERVED 11 YEARS, DID
FOUR DEPLOYMENTS. NOW I
SPECIALIZE IN COMMUNICATING
SPECIFICALLY AT CRITICAL
INCIDENTS. AND REALLY SCHOOLS, I
LIVE IN CALIFORNIA IN MAMMOTH
LAKES. I GOT TWO SMALL CHILDREN
THAT WILL SOON BE ENROLLED IN
SCHOOL. SO THIS IS SOMETHING
THAT'S NEAR AND DEAR TO MY
HEART. THE CHALLENGES FACING
FIRST RESPONDERS WHEN THEY
ARRIVE AT A 911 CALL ARE MANY,
AND IN THIS TIME, IT'S
SENSITIVE. IT'S DANGEROUS. FIRST
RESPONDERS OFTEN FIND THEMSELVES
WORKING WITH OTHER DEPARTMENTS
THAT THEY RARELY HAVE CONTACT
WITH. THEY'RE EXPECTED TO SIMPLY
KNOW HOW TO GET TO THE ART ROOM
OR THE CAFETERIA. BUT WE ALL
KNOW THAT THESE PROBLEMS ARE
COMPLEX AND UNDER STRESS.
EXTREMELY DIFFICULT SCHOOL
BLUEPRINTS OR FLOOR PLANS AS
THEY EXIST TODAY. THEY'RE
INACCURATE, AND THEY'RE NOT
DESIGNED FOR EMERGENCY RESPONSE.
ADDITIONALLY, THEY ARE
INACCESSIBLE IN THE DISPARATE
SOFTWARE SYSTEMS THAT FIRST
RESPONDERS USE, AS WELL AS
SCHOOL DISTRICT SOFTWARE
SYSTEMS. EXISTING BLUEPRINTS
WOULD OFTEN ADD CONFUSION TO AN
EMERGENCY SCENARIO VERSUS
PROVIDE ACTIONABLE INFORMATION.
DURING THAT CRITICAL INCIDENT
FROM SOME AFTER ACTIONS FROM
BOTH UVALDE AND SANDY HOOK, A
DIRECT QUOTE FROM THE AFTER
ACTION REPORT READS THE
SCHEMATIC MAPS OF THE CAMPUS
USED BY LAW ENFORCEMENT TO
IDENTIFY POTENTIAL POINTS OF
ENTRY WERE INACCURATE. LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS TESTIFIED
IN THE INVESTIGATIVE COMMITTEE
THAT, ASKED WHETHER THEY WOULD
PLAN TO GAIN ACCESS TO THE
CLASSROOM THROUGH WINDOWS, BUT
THEY WERE DETERRED BY THE
INACCURATE PLANS. IN THE CASE OF
SANDY HOOK, WHEN OFFICERS
CONDUCTED INITIAL AND SUBSEQUENT
SEARCHES OF THE SCHOOL, NEITHER
FLOOR PLANS NOR SCHEMATICS OF
THE SCHOOL WERE READILY
ACCESSIBLE. AB 2816 WILL ALLOW
COMPANIES IN THIS INDUSTRY TO
OFFER THESE MAPPING SERVICES TO
SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND FIRST
RESPONDERS, PROVIDING THEM WITH
THE NECESSARY TOOLS TO NAVIGATE
THE CAMPUS IN THE EVENT OF AN
EMERGENCY, ENHANCING
COMMUNICATION, SAVING TIME AND
SAVING LIVES. I THANK YOU AGAIN
FOR YOUR TIME AND I'M ALWAYS
REACHABLE FOR QUESTIONS IN THE
FUTURE. GREAT! THANK YOU SO MUCH
. ANYBODY ELSE HERE, WISHING TO
ADD ME TO TESTIMONY AND SUPPORT?
SEEING NONE. ANYBODY IN THE ROOM
IN OPPOSITION, SEEING NONE.
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE.
NØ THE BILL WHEN APPROPRIATE.
OH, WOW. WE'VE GOT A NEW, NEW
PLAYER. CONGRATS. AND I KNOW,
SENATOR CHOBOQ, YOU'VE ALREADY
SEEN THIS IN EDUCATION, SO I
THINK YOU HAD YOUR QUESTIONS
ANSWERED CORRECT. GOOD TO GO.
WE'RE GOOD TO GO THEN. SO WE
HAVE A MOTION. YOU MAY CLOSE.
YEAH. IT'S, MEMBERS. I HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SEE A DEMO OF THE
TYPE OF TECHNOLOGY THIS IS. IT'S
VERY, VERY IMPRESSIVE.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR. AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU. SIR. AT THIS
TIME, I RELUCTANTLY TURNED OVER
THE GAVEL TO OUR ESTEEMED CHAIR.
SENATOR DODD NØ. MUSIC.
WE'VE GOT A MOTION. ON THE. ALL
RIGHT. WE'LL NOW MOVE TO FILE
ITEM NUMBER 12, AB 2802
MAIENSCHEIN ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
WELCOME. GOOD MORNING. START
WHEN YOU'RE READY. THANK YOU SO
MUCH, MR. CHAIR AND MEMBERS, I
PRESENT HERE TO PRESENT AB 2802,
WHICH SEEKS TO CREATE MORE
GENDER INCLUSIVE OPTIONS FOR
HOUSING ARRANGEMENTS WITHIN
TRANSITIONAL HOUSING PLACEMENT
OR THP PROGRAMS. THP PROGRAMS
SERVE AS A LIFELINE FOR CURRENT
AND FORMER FOSTER YOUTH
SUFFERING FROM HOMELESSNESS,
OFFERING THEM TEMPORARY RELIEF
AND CRUCIAL SUPPORT SERVICES
TAILORED TO THEIR NEEDS.
HOWEVER, WHEN IMPLEMENTING THESE
PROGRAMS, PROVIDERS OFTEN
ENCOUNTER CHALLENGES IN PLACING
YOUTH STEMMING FROM EXCLUSIONARY
AND DISCRIMINATORY PRACTICES
PRESENT IN CERTAIN COUNTIES.
THESE CHALLENGES ARISE FROM
RIGID BINARY GENDER BASED RULES
FOR HOUSING ARRANGEMENTS. WE
MUST ACKNOWLEDGE THE HARSH
REALITIES FACED BY MANY
TRANSGENDER GENDER
NONCONFORMING, NONBINARY, AND
INTERSEX INDIVIDUALS IN THE
STATE. CURRENTLY, THE
DESIGNATION OF HOUSING VACANCIES
AS MALE AND FEMALE CREATES
BARRIERS FOR INDIVIDUALS,
SIBLINGS, AND CO-PARENTING YOUTH
WHO WISH TO LIVE TOGETHER BUT DO
NOT SHARE THE SAME GENDER
IDENTITY. HB 2802 AIMS TO
RECTIFY THESE DISPARITIES BY
ALLOWING FOSTER YOUTH IN
TRANSITIONAL HOUSING TO SHARE
ROOMS WITH ROOMMATES, SIBLINGS,
OR CO-PARENTS WHO DO NOT SHARE
THE SAME GENDER IDENTITY WITH
THE APPROVAL OF THE PROVIDER ON
A CASE BY CASE BASIS. BY
ENABLING SIBLINGS AND
CO-PARENTING YOUTH TO ROOM
TOGETHER, WE STRENGTHEN BONDS
AND PROVIDE A MORE SUPPORTIVE
ENVIRONMENT FOR THOSE WHO NEED
IT MOST. THIS BILL PROMOTES
FLEXIBILITY AND GENDER
IDENTIFICATION FOR ROOM
ASSIGNMENTS, ACCOMMODATING THE
DIVERSE NEEDS OF ALL CALIFORNIA
RESIDENTS, IRRESPECTIVE OF THEIR
GENDER IDENTITY OR EXPRESSION.
THIS UPHOLDS THE VALUES OF
COMPASSION, INCLUSIVITY AND
EQUITY. BY SUPPORTING THE BILL,
WE MAKE A SIGNIFICANT STEP
TOWARDS CREATING A MORE JUST
SOCIETY WHERE EVERY INDIVIDUAL,
REGARDLESS OF THEIR GENDER
IDENTITY, FEELS VALUED AND
SUPPORTIVE. I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AND I VOTE. THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER. WE'LL NOW MOVE
TO ANY LEAD WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT. PLEASE COME FORWARD.
GOOD AFTERNOON OR GOOD MORNING,
CHAIR AND MEMBERS, PAUL
BHATTACHARJEE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ALLIANCE OF CHILD AND
FAMILY SERVICES. HERE WE
REPRESENT 165 NONPROFIT,
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
WHICH RUN TRANSITIONAL HOUSING
PLACEMENT PROGRAMS AS WELL AS
OTHER PROGRAMS THAT SERVE
CURRENT AND FORMER FOSTER YOUTH.
THESE PROGRAMS HELP, TYPICALLY
THOSE OVER 18 YEARS OLD, TO A
FORMER AND CURRENT FOSTER YOUTH
TO HELP THEM THRIVE INTO
ADULTHOOD BY PROVIDING NECESSARY
LIFE SKILLS TRAINING, AS WELL AS
HOUSING THE CALIFORNIA ALLIANCE
IS PROUD TO SPONSOR AB 2802,
WHICH ALLOWS FOR GENDER
FLEXIBILITIES IN THESE TYPES.
THESE PROGRAMS SERVE A DIVERSE
POPULATION OF YOUTH, INCLUDING
LGBTQ PLUS YOUTH, AS WELL AS
PREGNANT AND CO-PARENTING YOUTH,
ACCORDING TO THE NATIONAL FOSTER
YOUTH INSTITUTE, ALMOST 60% OF
GIRLS IN FOSTER CARE BECOME
PREGNANT BY THE AGE OF 19.
DESPITE THE UNIQUE NEEDS OF THIS
POPULATION, SOME COUNTIES
REQUIRE PARTICIPANTS TO BE OF
THE SAME GENDER WHEN SHARING A
UNIT TOGETHER. THIS POSES GREAT
DIFFICULTIES FOR GENDER
EXPANSIVE YOUTH CO-PARENTS WHO
WISH TO RAISE A CHILD TOGETHER,
AND SIBLINGS WHO ARE OF
DIFFERENT GENDERS. THIS BILL WAS
INSPIRED BY LEVI NUNEZ, A TRANS
MALE AND FORMER FOSTER YOUTH WHO
HAD TO IDENTIFY AS FEMALE, HIS
GENDER ASSIGNED AT BIRTH IN A
THP TO AVOID HOMELESSNESS BY
CONTINUING TO ALLOW THIS
DISCRIMINATORY PRACTICE OF NOT
ALLOWING PROVIDERS TO PLACE
PARTICIPANTS TOGETHER REGARDLESS
OF GENDER, SIBLINGS AND
CO-PARENTING PARTNERS WILL ALSO
CONTINUE TO BE FORCED TO
SEPARATE AND NOT ALLOW TO LIVE
TOGETHER, SIMPLY BECAUSE THEY
ARE NOT OF THE SAME GENDER.
THUS, BY IMPLEMENTING A POLICY
STATEWIDE THAT ALLOWS FOR
PROVIDERS AND PARTICIPANTS TO
JOINTLY DECIDE ON THE BEST
PLACEMENT AND ROOMMATE OPTIONS
FOR THE YOUTH ON A CASE BY CASE
BASIS, REGARDLESS OF GENDER, WE
WILL BE ABLE TO BETTER
ACCOMMODATE THE NEEDS FOR ALL
FOSTER YOUTH IN THESE PROGRAMS.
FOR THESE REASONS, THE
CALIFORNIA ALLIANCE URGES AN AYE
VOTE ON AB 2802. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ANYONE ELSE
HERE IN SUPPORT STATE YOUR NAME,
YOUR AFFILIATION AND POSITION
ONLY. PLEASE. HOLLY. FOR ME, YOU
KNOW THAT. HOLLY, I KNOW THAT. I
KNOW THE RULES. HOLLY. FOR MANY
DANCES WITH LIGHTHOUSE PUBLIC
AFFAIRS ON BEHALF OF THE SAN
DIEGO HOUSING COMMISSION AND
SUPPORT. BECCA KRAMER MATTER ON
BEHALF OF ACLU CALIFORNIA ACTION
AND SUPPORT. THANK YOU, NICOLE
WATERMAN, ON BEHALF OF THE
CHILDREN'S PARTNERSHIP AND
SUPPORT AARON TAYLOR WITH
POLITICAL SOLUTIONS ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
MARRIAGE AND FAMILY THERAPISTS
AND SUPPORT. THANK YOU. ANYBODY
IN OPPOSITION? SEEING NONE. I'LL
BRING IT BACK TO THE DÍAS HERE.
ANYBODY WISHING TO COMMENT ON
THIS, I'M NOT SEEING ANY
COMMENTS. ASSEMBLY MEMBER, WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE? THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. WHEN WE GET A AT SOME
POINT TODAY, WE WILL GET A
QUORUM AND WE'LL BE VOTING ON
YOUR BILL. BUT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. WE'LL GO ON TO 14. ALL
RIGHT. IF THERE'S ANYONE. OKAY.
HERE'S ANOTHER. WE'LL NOW MOVE
TO FINAL ITEM NUMBER 14.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RODRIGUEZ. THANK
YOU FOR BEING PATIENT. THANK
YOU, MR. CHAIRMAN. MEMBERS, I'M
PLEASED TO PRESENT AB 2660 ON
BEHALF OF THE ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE
ON EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT. AS
ALWAYS, I APPRECIATE YOUR STAFF
AND THE WORK ON THIS BILL. THIS
BILL IS A WIN WIN FOR EMERGENCY
MANAGEMENT HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
NOT ONLY WILL INCREASE THE
CAPABILITIES OF LOCAL EMERGENCY
MANAGEMENT PROGRAMS, WHICH ARE
ROOTED IN THE COMMUNITIES THEY
SERVE AND TEND TO BE MORE
CULTURALLY COMPETENT, BUT BY
PASSING ON GRANT MATCH FUND
REQUIREMENTS, IT ALSO SAVES THE
STATE $12 MILLION EACH YEAR.
SPECIFICALLY, THIS BILL DIRECTS
CAL OES TO PROVIDE OUR LOCAL
EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT PARTNERS
WITH THE MAXIMUM AMOUNT OF
FEDERAL FUNDS PERMITTED UNDER
THE EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT
PERFORMANCE GRANT PROGRAM. THIS
BILL ENJOYS BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
AND HAS NO REGISTERED
OPPOSITION. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. ASSEMBLY MEMBER. IS THERE
ANYBODY HERE WISHING TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT? SEEING NONE, ANYBODY
WISHING TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION. SEEING NOBODY. WE'RE
MOVING BACK TO THE DAIS HERE,
SENATOR WILK. I MOVE IT WHEN
APPROPRIATE. PERFECT. WITH THAT
ASSEMBLY MEMBER, WE WILL. AS
SOON AS WE GET A QUORUM, WE'LL
BE VOTING ON YOUR BILL.
APPRECIATE. DO YOU WANT TO
CLOSE? I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU, THANK YOU,
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. WE'LL NOW
MOVE TO FILE ITEM NUMBER SEVEN,
AB 1511. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
SANTIAGO, WELCOME. THANK YOU,
MR. IF I MAY, MR. CHAIR, PLEASE.
YEAH, THANKS. THIS BILL WOULD
ESTABLISH THE DIVERSE ETHNIC AND
COMMUNITY MEDIA PROGRAM FOR THE
GOVERNOR IN THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE OF COMMUNITY
PARTNERSHIPS, STRATEGIC
COMMUNICATION TO ASSIST STATE
AGENCIES AND DEPARTMENTS TO
MAXIMIZE THE USE OF ETHNIC AND
COMMUNITY OUTLETS FOR
ADVERTISING AND OUTREACH, THIS
COMES AS AN EXPERIENCE THAT WE
HAD DURING COVID, BUT IT WAS
MUCH NEEDED EVEN BEFORE THEN.
AND IT AT THAT TIME, IT EXPOSED
THE EFFECTS AND CONSEQUENCES OF
THAT DISPARITIES, ACCESS TO
PUBLIC SERVICE INFORMATION AND
CRITICAL RESOURCES AND
ACCELERATED FINANCIAL
SUSTAINABILITY OF THESE OUTLETS.
I MEAN, BOTTOM LINE IS THESE
WERE TRUSTED COMMUNITY, OUTLETS
OR AT THE MEDIA THAT ALLOWED US
TO COMMUNICATE A CERTAIN AMOUNTS
OF INFORMATION. WE WANT TO TAKE
THAT AND MODEL IT ALSO, AFTER
WHAT HAS BEEN DONE IN NEW YORK
CITY, CHICAGO AND SEATTLE TO
CONTINUE A PROGRAM LIKE THIS.
THIS BILL SIMPLY REQUIRES STATE
AGENCIES, DEPARTMENTS THAT
EXPEND FUNDS ON ADVERTISING OR
OUTREACH TO DIRECT 30% OF ITS
EXPENDITURES TO ETHNIC AND
COMMUNITY MEDIA OUTLETS
BEGINNING THE YEAR 2026 AND
INCREASE ANNUALLY 50% BY 2728,
WE ACCEPT THE COMMITTEE'S
AMENDMENTS, AND WE'RE GRATEFUL
FOR THEM, AS REFLECTED IN THE
ANALYSIS, TO PROVIDE GREATER
FLEXIBILITY TO STATE AGENCIES
AND DEPARTMENTS BEYOND. ONE
WITNESS WITH US, ARTURO CARMONA,
WHO IS THE PRESIDENT OF LATINO
MEDIA COLLABORATIVE, IF YOU MAY
APPROACH, THAT WOULD BE OKAY
WITH US. THANKS. PLEASE WELCOME.
GOOD MORNING, CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
MY NAME IS ARTURO CARMONA. I'M
THE PRESIDENT OF LATINO MEDIA
COLLABORATIVE, CALIFORNIA'S
ETHNIC MEDIA SECTOR INCLUDES
ROUGHLY 300 MEDIA OUTLETS THAT
PUBLISH BROADCAST, THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA, SERVING AT LEAST 38
DIFFERENT ETHNIC, RACIAL AND
CULTURAL COMMUNITIES, AS
ASSEMBLYMEMBER SANTIAGO
MENTIONED, THEY HAVE A LONG
HISTORY OF BEING TRUSTED
COMMUNITY SPECIFIC SOURCES OF
INFORMATION, THE BILL THE BILL
EARMARKS A BASELINE OF FUNDING
TO ENSURE THAT THERE'S MORE
EQUITY IN THE WAY THE STATE
ADVERTISES, PARTICULARLY WITH,
SMALL AND MIDSIZE OUTLETS AND
RURAL OUTLETS, THE BILL HAS
ENJOYED, BIPARTISAN SUPPORT,
BECAUSE IT ADVANCES A COMMON
SENSE POLICY TO, SET SOME GROUND
RULES FOR STATE AGENCIES. WE'VE
HAD A MIXED RECORD, AGENCY TO
AGENCY. WE'VE HAD SOME STANDOUT
EXAMPLES OF AGENCIES THAT HAVE
TRULY PARTNERED WITH ETHNIC AND
COMMUNITY MEDIA, BUT OTHERS HAVE
FALLEN BEHIND, A COUPLE YEARS
AGO, WE PASSED A BILL THAT,
REQUIRED THAT THE STATE TRACK
THE WAY SPENDING IS HAPPENING
WITH, COMMUNITY OUTLETS AND
MEDIA OUTLETS ACROSS THE STATE.
AND WE CONFIRMED THAT, WE HAVE A
REAL CHALLENGE ENSURING THAT, AD
RESOURCES ARE FLOWING TO DIVERSE
STATE MEDIA OUTLETS THAT
COMMUNICATE WITH, WITH OUR
DIVERSE POPULATION. AND SO WE
WANT TO SET UP A, A MODEL IN
THIS STATE THAT, PRIORITIZES
EQUITY AND PRIORITIZES
COMMUNICATING WITH THOSE HARD TO
REACH AND SO WE ARE HAPPY TO
REPORT THAT, AS THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MENTIONED, WE'VE TAKEN A
NUMBER OF RECOMMENDATIONS FROM
STAKEHOLDERS, AGENCIES AND
ADMINISTRATION TO IMPROVE THE
BILL. AND WITH THAT, WE ASK FOR
YOUR SUPPORT. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. ANYBODY ELSE HERE IN
SUPPORT COME FORWARD, STATE YOUR
NAME, ORGANIZATION AND YOUR
POSITION. HI, GOOD MORNING,
ESPERANZA GUEVARA. ON BEHALF OF
COLOGNE NEWS, THE MANAGING
DIRECTOR FOR THE ORGANIZATION
HERE IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING. DANIEL SANCHEZ,
CALIFORNIA ADVOCACY HERE ON
BEHALF OF LA CORPORATIVA
CAMPESINA DE CALIFORNIA AND ALSO
THE CALEXICO WELLNESS CENTER IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING.
ALEJANDRO SOLIS HERE ON BEHALF
OF COMITE CIVICO DEL VALLE, LOS
AMIGOS DE LA COMUNIDAD, MEXICAN
AMERICAN OPPORTUNITY FOUNDATION,
ALL IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. ANYBODY IN OPPOSITION?
SEEING NONE. WE'LL COME BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE. SUBCOMMITTEE I'LL
MOVE THE BILL WHEN APPROPRIATE.
OKAY. THANK YOU. VERY GOOD. SO,
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE? I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE, MR. CHAIR, WHEN YOU SAID
COMMITTEE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
APPRECIATE IT. OKAY. WE'LL NOW
MOVE TO FILE ITEM NUMBER 22, AB
3089. IT'S A MEMBER, ASSEMBLY
MEMBER JONES SAWYER. BUT SENATOR
BRADFORD WILL BE PRESENTING. IS
THAT A GOOD IDEA? IF WE DIDN'T
HAVE FUN IN HERE, WE'D GO CRAZY.
YEAH, BUT THIS DOESN'T HELP HIM,
SENATOR. THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR.
I'M HERE TO PRESENT AB 3089 ON
BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER JOAN
SAWYER, 3089 IS THE CALIFORNIA
APOLOGY ACT FOR THE PERPETRATION
OF GROSS HUMAN RIGHTS VIOLATIONS
AND CRIMES AGAINST HUMANITY,
WITH SPECIAL CONSIDERATION FOR
AFRICAN AMERICAN SLAVES AND
THEIR DESCENDANTS. MR. JONES AND
I, APPRECIATE THE WORK THAT THE
COMMITTEE HAS DONE IN 2020, THE
CALIFORNIA ASSEMBLY CREATED THE
FIRST IN THE NATION TASK FORCE
TO STUDY AND DEVELOP REPARATIONS
PROPOSALS WITH SPECIAL
CONSIDERATION FOR AFRICAN
AMERICANS. MR. JONES AND I HAD
THE PRIVILEGE OF SERVING ON THAT
COMMITTEE FOR TWO YEARS. THE
TASK FORCE HEARD COUNTLESS HOURS
OF TESTIMONY AND RECEIVED
THOUSANDS OF PAGES OF DOCUMENTS
FROM STATE AGENCIES, HISTORIANS,
ECONOMISTS, BUSINESSES,
ATTORNEYS, PROFESSORS, FAMILIES,
FORMER SLAVE OWNERS, AND THE
DESCENDANTS OF SLAVES AND
SHARECROPPERS. BASED ON THE
EVIDENCE, THE TASK FORCE ISSUED
ITS REPORT AT 1100 PAGES, A
PAINSTAKING STAKING, RECITATION,
OF THE DEPLORABLE TREATMENT OF
AFRICAN AMERICAN SLAVES AND THE
WAYS IN WHICH CALIFORNIA AND THE
UNITED STATES BENEFITED FROM
FORCED HUMAN SLAVE LABOR, AND
HOW IT CONTINUES TO SUBJUGATE
BLACK CALIFORNIANS TODAY. AS
REQUIRED BY STATUTE, THE TASK
FORCE WAS REQUIRED TO INCLUDE IN
ITS FINDINGS HOW THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WILL OFFER A FORMAL
APOLOGY ON BEHALF OF THE PEOPLE
OF CALIFORNIA FOR THE
PERPETRATION OF GROSS HUMAN
RIGHTS VIOLATIONS AND CRIMES
AGAINST HUMANITY AND AFRICAN
AMERICAN SLAVES IN THE SENATE.
THIS BILL IS A FULFILLMENT OF
THAT CHARGE. 3089 IS THE NEXT
STEP IN THE TRUTH AND
RECONCILIATION PROCESS. BY
OFFERING A FORMAL APOLOGY OF
PAST WRONGS, CALIFORNIA WILL
JOIN NINE OTHER STATES THAT HAVE
OFFERED SOME FORM OF APOLOGY FOR
THEIR ROLE IN SLAVERY. ALABAMA
ALABAMA, CONNECTICUT, DELAWARE,
FLORIDA, MARYLAND, NEW JERSEY,
NORTH CAROLINA, TENNESSEE, AND
VIRGINIA HAVE ALL ENACTED SOME
FORM OF APOLOGY FOR THEIR ROLE
IN THE SLAVE TRADE, EVEN THOUGH
CALIFORNIA ENTERED THE UNION AS
A FREE STATE IN NAME ONLY, THEY
DID EVERYTHING THAT A SLAVE
STATE DID. IF YOU WERE BROUGHT
HERE AS A SLAVE, YOU WERE
TREATED AS SUCH. IF YOU GAVE
BIRTH, YOUR CHILD WAS BORN A
SLAVE, AND IF YOU RAN AWAY, WE
HAD A FUGITIVE SLAVE ACT THAT
RETURNED YOU BACK TO THE STATE
AND PLANTATION IN WHICH YOU
ESCAPED FROM. SO WE HAD A HAND
IN PERPETRATING THE OPPRESSION
OF BLACK CALIFORNIANS. THIS BILL
IS AN OPPORTUNITY TO CONFRONT
THOSE TOUGH TRUTHS IN A
MEANINGFUL WAY. IT'S LONG PAST
THE TIME OF THE STATE TO
ACKNOWLEDGE ITS ROLE AND
RESPONSIBILITIES FOR THE
ATROCITIES THAT PROMOTED AND
FACILITATED THE INSTITUTION OF
SLAVERY. STATE OF CALIFORNIA IS
AND SHOULD CONTINUE TO AFFIRM
ITS ROLE IN PROTECTING AND
UPLIFTING THE DESCENDANTS OF
ENSLAVED PEOPLE WHO HAVE BEEN
HARMED BY THE LEGACY LEGACIES OF
STATE SANCTIONED POLICIES WE
CONTINUE TO IGNORE IF WE
CONTINUE TO IGNORE OUR PAST, WE
ARE DOOMED TO REPEAT IT. SO I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE VOTE.
SENATOR THANK YOU SENATOR.
ANYBODY WISHING TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT, PLEASE COME FORWARD.
CLIFTON WILSON, ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ACADEMY OF CHILD AND
ADOLESCENT PSYCHIATRY IN
SUPPORT, I TRY TO DO IT FASTER
FOR YOU. VERY GOOD. SAMANTHA
JOHNSON, ON BEHALF OF THE
GREATER SACRAMENTO URBAN LEAGUE
IN SUPPORT. NATALIE KNOX, ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF LOCAL
CONSERVATION, CAUSE AND SUPPORT.
BECCA KRAMER MATTER ON BEHALF OF
ACLU CALIFORNIA ACTION AND
SUPPORT. ANDY LIEBMAN BAUM, ON
BEHALF OF THE COUNTY OF LOS
ANGELES IN SUPPORT. ANY CHILD
WITH THE CALIFORNIA TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION AND SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. ANYBODY IN OPPOSITION?
SEEING NOBODY COMING FORWARD,
WE'LL MOVE TO THE SUBCOMMITTEE.
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS? JUST
WANT TO THANK OUR GOOD SENATOR
FOR PRESENTING THIS ON BEHALF OF
OUR ASSEMBLY MEMBER, JOAN SAWYER
. AND THIS IS PART OF THE UN
PROCESS, FIRST STEP IS APOLOGY.
AND HERE WE ARE GRATEFUL FOR
YOUR WORK AND LEADERSHIP. AND
I'M HAPPY TO MOVE THE BILL WHEN
THE TIME IS RIGHT. THANK YOU
ALL. SEEING NONE, WE'RE STILL A
SUBCOMMITTEE. AND AS SOON AS WE
GET A QUORUM, WE'LL BE VOTING ON
THIS. WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE,
SENATOR? AS STATED, THE FIRST
STEP IN ANY HEALING PROCESS IS
FIRST, AN APOLOGY. THIS BEGINS
THAT PROCESS OF HEALING. AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU. BEFORE WE MOVE TO THE
NEXT. WELL, WE DON'T HAVE A
AUTHOR HERE. WE NEED
ASSEMBLYMEMBERS CALDERON LI
QUIRK-SILVA AND WILK. EXCUSE ME.
WICKS IS RIGHT HERE. THIS THE
SEA LOOK. KIND OF LOOK LIKE AN
L, BUT IT WAS ASSEMBLY, SO IT'S
NOT A STAFF PROBLEM. IT'S A
CHAIRMAN PROBLEM. CALDERON LI
QUIRK-SILVA AND WICKS, WOULD YOU
PLEASE COME AND PRESENT YOUR
BILLS, PLEASE? THANK YOU. SORRY
FOR WHAT? OH, I DON'T CARE. I'M
NOT GOING TO. RECESS OR NO. ARE
WE. ARE WE?
29. 23. OH, YEAH. IT GOES FASTER
AND YOU HAVE A DIFFERENT CHAIR.
YEAH. NO, THAT'S NOT TRUE. HE
MOVED. HE MOVES IT. ALSO, WE
NEED THREE SENATORS TO HAVE A
QUORUM SO WE CAN DO THIS
PEOPLE'S BUSINESS. PLEASE COME
DOWN AND ESTABLISH QUORUM. SO
FIRST. SO WHEN I FIRST GOT UP
FIRST, GOT UP HERE, I DID. AND
SO THEY DO THEIR TRAINING LIKE
WE HAVE THIS ONE MEAN SOMETHING
TO US HERE AND SENT US BACK HOME
AND I GROCERY SHOP I CALLED HIM
BRANCH. BUT THEN YOU PULL UP AND
PULL UP. SO I GO DOWN THERE.
IT'S A CHRYSLER 300. SO WOW,
THIS IS AWESOME. AND THEN I GET
IN AND I SMELL WOMEN'S GROUP Dð
AND THEN LOOK IN THE GLOVE BOX.
AND IT WAS LOIS WOLF CAR. IT.
RANDY, CAN YOU GO ARREST THEM
AND BRING THEM IN, SEE WHAT WE
CAN DO IF YOU'RE THERE? ARE YOU
KIDDING? RIGHT BUT WATCH THIS
TOMORROW. YEAH I THINK THANK YOU
SO MUCH. YOU'RE A GOOD GUY,
KELLY. NOT REALLY. JUST ASK THE
FRIENDS OF JUST THIS MORNING.
NO, NOT EVEN THIS MORNING. IT'S
JUST PUBLIC SAFETY. SO.
I GUESS. I'M WATCHING THE
SCREEN. YEAH.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER'S. CALDERON LI
QUIRK-SILVA AND WICKS. PLEASE
COME TO THE MEETING. COMMITTEE
HEARING TO PRESENT YOUR BILLS.
WE'LL NOW MOVE TO FINAL ITEM
NUMBER 23, AB 3150. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER QUIRK-SILVA. GOOD
MORNING. WELCOME. GOOD MORNING,
MR. CHAIR. AND MEMBERS. TODAY I
PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL 3150,
WHICH STRAIGHTENS THE ACCURACY
OF CALIFORNIA'S FIRE HAZARD
SEVERITY ZONE MAPS BY ALLOWING
THE STATE FIRE MARSHAL TO
CONSIDER MAP REVISIONS THROUGH A
MEET AND CONFER PROCESS. THESE
MAPS EVALUATE HAZARD BASED ON
THE PHYSICAL CONDITIONS THAT
CREATE A LIKELIHOOD AND EXPECTED
FIRE BEHAVIOR OVER A 30 TO 50
YEAR PERIOD WITHOUT CONSIDERING
MITIGATION MEASURES. MEASURES
SUCH AS HOME HARDENING,
DEFENSIBLE SPACE, VEGETATION
MANAGEMENT, OR FUEL REDUCTION
EFFORTS. AB 3150 IS A MEASURE
THAT ESTABLISHES A MECHANISM TO
UPDATE THE FIRE HAZARD SEVERITY
ZONE MAPS FOR 50 ACRES OR MORE,
SIMILAR TO THE PROCESS USED FOR
FLOOD MAP REVISIONS. AB 3150
MOVES CALIFORNIA TOWARDS A
SAFER, MORE RESILIENT FUTURE
WHERE EVERYONE CAN LIVE, WORK,
AND THRIVE. WITH ME TODAY TO
PROVIDE TESTIMONY AND SUPPORT
AND TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS IS
MR. SILVIO FERRARI WITH THE
CALIFORNIA BUILDING INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION, CBIA AND SPONSORS
OF AB 3001 50. YEAH GOOD
MORNING, MR. CHAIR. MEMBERS.
SILVIO FERRARI, ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA BUILDING INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION HERE IS A PROUD
SPONSOR. I DON'T THINK I CAN SAY
IT MUCH BETTER THAN THE AUTHOR
DID. AND GIVEN THE TIME AND THE
PRESSURE OF THE DAY, I THINK I
WOULD JUST SAY THIS IS A REALLY
IMPORTANT BILL TO ENSURE THAT AS
WE MOVE FORWARD, WE ARE GETTING
THE BEST AVAILABLE DATA SCIENCE
AND WHAT IS ACTUALLY HAPPENING
ON THE GROUND TO MAKE SURE WE
HAVE ACCURATE MAPS. SO I WOULD
URGE YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU.
AND IT WAS ALSO ASKED TO SAY
SUPPORT FOR THE CALIFORNIA
BUSINESS PROPERTIES ASSOCIATION.
IS THAT OKAY? ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT? GOOD
MORNING. LIZZIE KUTSUNA HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE COUNTY OF KERN IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. ANYBODY IN
OPPOSITION? HI. NATALIE KNOX, ON
BEHALF OF MIDPENINSULA REGIONAL
OPEN SPACE DISTRICT, IN
REGRETFUL OPPOSITION. OKAY.
SEEING NOBODY ELSE COMING
FORWARD, I'LL TURN IT TO THE
SUBCOMMITTEE. ANY QUESTIONS?
COMMENTS? I'LL OFFER COMMENT
WILL BE HONORED. SENATOR SATO.
NO THIS IS A GOOD BILL. WHAT'S
HAPPENING? A LOT IN ESPECIALLY
DISTRICTS THAT HAVE LARGE BRUSH
AREAS THAT HAVE TRADITIONALLY
BEEN VERY HIGH HAZARD AREAS.
ACTUALLY, SOME OF THOSE ARE
BEING REPLACED BY NEIGHBORHOODS.
AND THE ONLY MAP THAT THE MAP
THAT SHOWS THAT IT'S A HIGH
HAZARD AREA IS NOW ACTUALLY
UNDERNEATH THE NEIGHBORHOOD
ITSELF. AND SO IT IS NOT, IN
FACT, A HIGH HAZARD
NEIGHBORHOOD. AND THEY CAN'T GET
A NEW MAP IN A TIMELY FASHION,
SO THAT THEY CAN GET THE
INSURANCE NEEDED TO BE ABLE TO
GET A MORTGAGE. SO THIS IS A
HAMPERING OUR ABILITY. A LOT OF
PEOPLE'S ABILITY TO GET THEIR
HOUSE. AND IN A TIMELY FASHION,
IT'S SLOWING DOWN THE HOUSING
INDUSTRY AND FOR NO REAL GOOD
REASON OTHER THAN WE'RE JUST NOT
UPDATING OUR MAPS FAST ENOUGH.
YOUR BILL APPEARS. I THINK WE
HEARD IT BEFORE. IT APPEARS TO
BE ABLE TO ADDRESS THAT. AND SO
I APPRECIATE YOU TACKLING THIS.
AND, BECAUSE IF SOMEBODY FROM A
REGION OUT WHERE IT'S WE DON'T
HAVE THAT BRUSH, DOES IT? PEOPLE
DON'T UNDERSTAND AS WELL. I
GUESS THEY THINK IT'S SELFISH,
BUT NO, YOU'RE FROM A REGION
THAT ISN'T AS IMPACTED. BUT
CERTAINLY THIS IS A GOOD BILL.
AND SO WE'LL BE SUPPORTING IT
SOMEDAY WHEN WE DO HAVE A
QUORUM, I'D BE MORE THAN HAPPY
TO MOVE IT. OKAY, GOOD. OH,
THAT'S GOOD. GOOD COMMENT,
PLEASE. CHAIR, PLEASE. YES.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER QUIRK-SILVA,
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD, OFTEN I HEAR FROM MY
CONSTITUENTS, HOW ARE WE GOING
TO SOLVE THE INSURANCE CRISIS IN
CALIFORNIA, AND YOUR BILL REALLY
DOES EMPHASIZE THAT
MULTI-PRONGED APPROACH, WE HAVE
SO MUCH, LIABILITY RIGHT NOW IN
OUR STATE AROUND CATASTROPHIC
LOSS WHEN IT COMES TO WILDFIRES
AND PROPERTY AND BUSINESSES, AND
I THINK THAT YOUR BILL, I JUST
WANT TO APPRECIATE YOU LOOKING
AT IT FROM ANOTHER LENS AND
HELPING US TO, TO RIGHTSIZE AND
BRING EXISTING LAWS UP TO DATE
SO THAT ALL OF THE HOMEOWNERS
AND PROPERTY OWNERS THAT ARE
DOING EVERYTHING THEY CAN TO
BUILD DEFENSIBLE SPACE, CAN HAVE
THAT RECOGNIZED IN LEGISLATION
AS WELL. SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU. SENATOR. ANYBODY ELSE
WE ARE IN NEED OF ONE SENATOR TO
COME DOWN HERE. WE MAY HAVE A
QUORUM. SO, MISS BRADFORD. SO,
IS WHEN WE HAVE A QUORUM, WE
WILL TAKE SENATOR SATO'S MOTION,
MAKE IT ENSHRINE IT. AND, WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE? I WOULD, I DO
APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS,
ESPECIALLY FROM, OUR FAVORITE
FIRE EXPERT AND WITH THAT, I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. WE ARE IN
NEED OF AN ASSEMBLY. AUTHOR
CALDERON LEE OR WICKS. PLEASE
COME TO 12, ROOM 1200. I'M
TEXTING ARCHULETA. RIGHT NOW.
WHO ELSE SHOULD WE TEXT?
IF ONLY EVERY COMMITTEE WAS
SITTING THERE AND WAITING FOR ME
TO ARRIVE. OKAY NOW WE'RE GOING
TO MOVE TO FILE ITEM NUMBER 24,
AB 3211. ASSEMBLY MEMBER WICKS.
GOOD MORNING. WELCOME. THANK
YOU, MR. CHAIRMAN. AND MEMBERS.
SORRY TO KEEP YOU WAITING. I'M
HERE TO PRESENT AB 3211, THE
CALIFORNIA PROVIDENCE
AUTHENTICITY AND WATERMARKING
STANDARDS ACT. THAT IS A
MOUTHFUL. FIRST, I GIVE MY
THANKS TO THE COMMITTEE STAFF.
THE HARD WORKING COMMITTEE STAFF
FOR THEIR ENGAGEMENT AND
WILLINGNESS TO WORK WITH OUR
OFFICE ON SUCH A TIGHT TIMELINE.
AND I'M AND I COMMIT THAT MY
OFFICE WILL CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH YOUR STAFF SHOULD THE BILL
MOVE FORWARD TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE. FACED
WITH A NEWLY CHAOTIC MEDIA
LANDSCAPE MADE UP OF GENERATIVE
AI AND SUBSTANTIALLY MODIFIED
CONTENT ALONGSIDE HUMAN
GENERATED CONTENT, REAL
PHOTOGRAPHS, VIDEO AND AUDIO, IT
HAS BECOME INCREASINGLY
DIFFICULT TO KNOW WHAT TO TRUST,
WHAT IS REAL AND WHAT IS FAKE.
UNDRESSING APPS ARE RAMPANT NOW.
THEY ALLOW A USER TO PAY $1 AND
SPEND LESS THAN 20 MINUTES TO
CREATE CONVINCING DEEP FAKE AND
NON-CONSENSUAL IMAGERY. WOMEN
AND GIRLS ARE PARTICULARLY
VULNERABLE AND HAVE EXPERIENCED
HARMS IN AT LEAST THREE OF
CALIFORNIA'S MIDDLE AND HIGH
SCHOOLS. WE ALSO OBVIOUSLY HAVE
THE ISSUE AROUND ELECTIONS AND
INTEGRITY, AND ENSURING THAT
WHAT CANDIDATES ARE SAYING IS
ACTUALLY REAL AND THAT AS AS
CONSTITUENTS SEE THAT CONTENT,
THEY KNOW IF IT IS REAL OR IF IT
IS FAKE. SO WE AS POLICY MAKERS,
NEED TO ENSURE THAT OUR MEDIA
CONSUMERS ARE ABLE TO DISCERN
WHAT IS REAL FROM WHAT IS FAKE.
AB 3211 PRESENTS THREE WAYS TO
DO THIS ONE. REQUIRE ALL CONTENT
FROM GENERATED CHEN CHEN I, AS
THEY SAY, TO BE LABELED AS
SYNTHETIC TO REQUIRE ALL CONTENT
FROM RECORDING DEVICES TO BE
LABELED AS NON SYNTHETIC, AND
THREE REQUIRE ALL ONLINE
PLATFORMS TO DISPLAY THESE
LABELS. DIGIMARC, A WORLD LEADER
IN FINANCIAL AND DATA SECURITY,
IS ALREADY PROVIDING THESE
TECHNOLOGIES AND LARGE LANGUAGE
MODEL. LARGE LANGUAGE MODEL
DEVELOPERS LIKE OPENAI AND
GOOGLE ARE BETA TESTING THESE
TECHNOLOGIES WITH GENERAL USERS.
WE NEED TO ENSURE THAT WE DON'T
LET ANOTHER TECHNOLOGY RUN
RAMPANT AND HURT OUR KIDS, AND
WE NEED TO PROVIDE MUCH NEEDED
GUARDRAILS. THIS BILL HAS
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT THROUGH THE
ASSEMBLY PROCESS, AND WE
CONTINUE TO WORK COLLABORATIVELY
ON AMENDMENTS WITH STAKEHOLDERS,
INCLUDING MICROSOFT, OPENAI,
GOOGLE, ADOBE, AND MANY OTHERS.
AND I'LL SAY BEFORE WE GET TO MY
WITNESSES, I HAVE LIKE
AGGRESSIVELY SOUGHT OUT
OPPOSITION TO COME MEET WITH OUR
OFFICE INDUSTRY. WE'VE MET WITH
A LOT OF THE DIFFERENT BIG TECH
COMPANIES. I WANT TO CREATE A
BILL THAT ACTUALLY CAN BE
IMPLEMENTED THAT CAN BE USEFUL
WORKING WITH INDUSTRY. WE
CONTINUE TO HAVE THOSE
CONVERSATIONS. YOU KNOW, WHEN
YOU'RE REGULATING, AS YOU ALL
KNOW, PARTICULARLY IN THE TECH
SPACE, IT'S VERY TECHNICAL AND
IT'S HARD AND IT'S THORNY. AND
SO FROM MY PERSPECTIVE, WE I
REALLY NEED TO BE HAVE INDUSTRY
AT THE TABLE TO TRY TO CREATE
SOMETHING THAT THAT CAN BE
ACHIEVABLE. WE'RE ALSO VERY
MINDFUL OF THE EU'S REGULATIONS,
THE FACT THAT THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT IS PUTTING FORTH
DIFFERENT IDEAS, THE FACT THAT
OTHER STATES ARE PUTTING FORTH
IDEAS AS WELL. SO CONFORMITY
AROUND TIMELINES OF
IMPLEMENTATION HAS BEEN REALLY
IMPORTANT TO MAKE IT EASIER FOR
THE COMPANIES TO IMPLEMENT AS
WELL AS, DEFINITIONS AND MAKING
SURE WE'RE TRYING TO BE AS
MINDFUL AS WE CAN. THE SENATOR
UMBERG HAD THE BILL BEFORE, AND
HIS COMMITTEE HE PROVIDED, I
THINK, SOME USEFUL AMENDMENTS TO
THAT EFFECT AROUND THE IDEA OF
CONFORMITY, SO THAT WE'RE ALL
TRYING TO SORT OF, YOU KNOW,
POINT OUR, OUR ROAD, THE BOAT IN
THE SAME DIRECTION, SO TO SPEAK,
AROUND THE REGULATION. BUT I DO
BELIEVE THIS BILL WILL REPRESENT
SOMETHING THAT IS ACHIEVABLE.
IT'S SORT OF THE LOWEST HANGING
FRUIT I SEE AROUND AI
REGULATION. AND I THINK WE NEED
TO APPROACH AI REGULATION, TO
HAVE THE RIGHT GUARDRAILS, BUT
STILL ALLOW FOR THE INNOVATION
AND ALL THE ECONOMIC GROWTH THAT
COMES FROM THAT. AND I THINK
THAT'S REALLY IMPORTANT,
ESPECIALLY HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
SO WITH THAT, WE HAVE DAVID
HARRIS, PROFESSOR WITH THE HAAS
SCHOOL OF BUSINESS AT UC
BERKELEY, TESTIFYING AS WELL AS
KEN WANG. BOTH OUR SPONSOR
GROUPS FROM CITED AND SO I WILL
ALLOW THEM TO TESTIFY. COULD YOU
HOLD ONE SECOND, PLEASE? SORRY
TO HAVE TO DO THIS, BUT WE'RE
GOING TO ESTABLISH A LONG NEEDED
QUORUM HERE. YOU'RE JUST
ESTABLISHING QUORUM WITH TWO
MORE BILLS LEFT FOR YOU. DODD
HERE. DODD HERE. WILK PRESENT.
WILK PRESENT. ALVARADO. GIL
ALVARADO HERE. ARCHULETA ASHBY.
BRADFORD GLASER. GLASER. HERE.
JONES NGUYEN. HERE. NGUYEN. HERE
OKOBO. OKOBO. PRESENT PADILLA.
PRESENT. PADILLA. PRESENT
PORTANTINO. ROTH RUBIO. CERRADO
CERRADO. HERE. SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS. SMALLWOOD CUEVAS. HERE.
I WOULD LIKE TO TAKE THE
PRIVILEGE OF BEING THE CHAIR TO
CONGRATULATE SENATOR GLASER FOR
THE FIRST TIME. THAT HE HAS BEEN
IN THE ROOM TO ESTABLISH A
QUORUM ON THIS COMMITTEE THIS
YEAR. YOU'RE AMAZING. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH, SIR. NOW THAT WE'VE
GOTTEN THAT OUT OF THE WAY,
WELCOME. THIS MIC ON. PERFECT.
GOOD MORNING, CHAIR MEMBERS. MY
NAME IS KEN WANG, AND I'M THE
SENIOR POLICY ADVOCATE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA INITIATIVE FOR
TECHNOLOGY AND DEMOCRACY, OR
SITED FOR SHORT. WE'RE PROUD TO
SPONSOR AB 3211, WHICH WOULD
REQUIRE WATERMARKING AND
PROVENANCE DATA FOR CONTENT
GENERATED BY GENERATIVE AI.
SYSTEMS CITED CAME TOGETHER TO
SEEK STATE LEVEL SOLUTIONS TO
THE THREAT THAT DISINFORMATION,
ARTIFICIAL INTELLIGENCE,
DEEPFAKES AND OTHER EMERGING
TECHNOLOGIES POSE TO OUR
DEMOCRACY AND OUR ELECTIONS. WE
APPROACH THESE ISSUES THROUGH A
CROSS-DISCIPLINARY APPROACH
ADVISED BY LEADERS FROM CIVIL
RIGHTS AND CIVIC ENGAGEMENT, LAW
AND PUBLIC POLICY, INDUSTRY AND
TECH, AND MORE TO THAT END,
CITED IS PROUD TO SPONSOR AB
3211, WHICH WOULD ADD AN
IMPORTANT TOOL TO OUR ARSENAL TO
HELP STEM THE TIDE OF AI
GENERATED DISINFORMATION. IT IS
NO SECRET THAT WE ARE ALL
WITNESSING A RAPID EROSION OF
TRUST IN OUR CIVIC INSTITUTIONS
AND IN OUR INFORMATION ECOSYSTEM
WITHOUT A THOUGHTFUL POLICY
INTERVENTION, GENERATIVE AI HAS
THE POTENTIAL TO SUPERCHARGE
THIS TRUTH, DECAY. VARIOUS
EFFORTS HAVE BEEN INITIATED AS
THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER MENTIONED IN
THE UI ACT, AND LOCALLY OR
FEDERALLY. THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION'S EXECUTIVE ORDER
ALSO TASKED THE DEPARTMENT OF
COMMERCE TO DEVELOP GUIDANCE FOR
CONTENT AUTHENTICATION. CITED
BELIEVES THAT CALIFORNIA HAS THE
OPPORTUNITY AS THE HOME OF
SILICON VALLEY AND THE HEARTLAND
OF AI INNOVATION, TO LEAD THE US
RESPONSE TO THESE THREATS. AB
3211 REPRESENTS AN IMPORTANT
FIRST STEP FOR OUR STATE TO
SHAPE THE SOLUTION. WE'RE
LOOKING FORWARD TO THE
CONTINUING AND THOUGHTFUL DIALOG
THAT WE'VE HAD WITH STAKEHOLDERS
AND OPPOSITION, AND WE WOULD
LIKE TO THANK ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WICKS FOR HER LEADERSHIP ON THIS
ISSUE AND FOR THE COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR WORKING WITH US AS WE
CONTINUE TO REFINE THE BILL. AND
WITH THAT, I'LL TURN IT OVER TO
SENIOR POLICY ADVISOR DAVID
HARRIS TO WALK THROUGH THE
TECHNICAL ASPECTS OF THE BILL.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING. GOOD MORNING, CHAIR
DODD AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. IT'S AN HONOR TO BE
ABLE TO SPEAK WITH YOU ABOUT AB
3211, THE CALIFORNIA PROVENANCE,
AUTHENTICITY AND WATERMARKING
STANDARDS. MY NAME IS DAVID
HARRIS, AND I'M HERE TODAY IN MY
CAPACITY AS SENIOR POLICY
ADVISOR TO CITED AI IS A
POWERFUL TOOL THAT CAN BRING
GREAT BENEFITS TO PEOPLE, BUT IF
NOT GOVERN JUDICIOUSLY, IT CAN
CAUSE GREAT HARM. YOU'VE ALREADY
HEARD FROM ASSEMBLY MEMBER WIX
ABOUT THE DANGERS OF
NON-CONSENSUAL INTIMATE IMAGERY
AND ELECTION DEEPFAKES. AI IS
PARTICULARLY POWERFUL IN THE
AREA OF MISINFORMATION
CAMPAIGNS. IT CAN SUPERCHARGE
THESE EFFORTS. WE'RE ALREADY
FAMILIAR WITH THIS BECAUSE OF
THE RUSSIAN EFFORTS IN 2016 TO
UNDERMINE THE US ELECTIONS, AND
WE'VE ALREADY BEEN WARNED BY THE
DEPARTMENT OF HOMELAND SECURITY
THAT CHINA, RUSSIA AND NORTH
KOREA ARE ALREADY MAKING PLANS
TO INTERFERE IN THE 2024 US
ELECTION. WATERMARKING IS THE
BEST TOOL AVAILABLE TO ALLOW US
TO IDENTIFY WHAT CONTENT IS
PRODUCED BY AI, AND WHAT CONTENT
IS AUTHENTIC, AB 3211 REQUIRES
THAT THAT TECH COMPANIES, AI
COMPANIES IN PARTICULAR MAKE
GOOD ON PROMISES THAT THEY'VE
ALREADY MADE TO ADD WATERMARKING
TO THEIR AI SYSTEMS. THESE
PROMISES WERE FIRST MADE IN THE
WHITE HOUSE VOLUNTARY AI
COMMITMENTS ALMOST A YEAR AGO.
THEY WERE MADE AGAIN AT THE
MUNICH SECURITY CONFERENCES AI
ELECTION ACCORD IN FEBRUARY OF
THIS YEAR. YET THE COMPANIES
MAKING AI TOOLS HAVE FAILED TO
DELIVER IN A SERIOUS WAY ON
THESE PROMISES. NOW, COUNTER TO
STATEMENTS FROM THE OPPOSITION,
WE KNOW THAT THIS BILL IS.
REQUIREMENTS ARE NOT IMPOSSIBLE
TO COMPLY WITH. COMPLIANCE CAN'T
BE IMPOSSIBLE BECAUSE THE TECH
HAS ALREADY BEEN DEPLOYED BY
GOOGLE JUST OVER A MONTH AGO
NOW, ANY AI GENERATED AUDIO,
IMAGES, VIDEO AND TEXT FROM
GOOGLE'S GENERATIVE AI SYSTEMS
ARE WATERMARKED, AND IF THEY
WORK AS ADVERTISED, THEY'RE VERY
LIKELY TO ALREADY BE COMPLIANT
WITH AB 3211. GIVEN THAT IT'S
ALREADY BEEN ALMOST A YEAR SINCE
THE WHITE HOUSE AI COMMITMENTS
WERE MADE AND WE'VE SEEN LITTLE
PROGRESS, I SEE NO OTHER OPTION
THAN TO LEGALLY COMPEL THE AI
COMPANIES OF THE WORLD OPERATING
HERE IN CALIFORNIA TO ADD
WATERMARKS AND PROVENANCE
INFORMATION TO THEIR GENERATIVE
AI CONTENT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
. ANYBODY IN SUPPORT? PLEASE
COME FORWARD. CLIFTON WILSON ON
BEHALF OF THE CITY AND COUNTY OF
SAN FRANCISCO BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. ANYBODY IN OPPOSITION? NO
WE HAVE ONE MORE. THANK YOU, MR.
CHAIR. AND MEMBERS, DILLON
HOFFMAN, ON BEHALF OF TECHNET,
WE ARE RESPECTFULLY OPPOSED TO
AB 3211. WE FULLY AGREE WITH THE
INTENT TO CREATE GREATER TRUST
AND USER GENERATED CONTENT
ONLINE BY FOSTERING THE ADOPTION
OF CONTENT PROVENANCE
VERIFICATIONS AND WATERMARKS IN
JUST A VERY QUICKLY, SAY, WE'VE
ALSO SUPPORTED EFFORTS TO
ADDRESS SOME OF THE MORE
CONCERNING AND DANGEROUS USE
CASES OF AI. WE'VE SUPPORTED
BILLS TO CRIMINALIZE THE USE OF
AI TO GENERATE CHILD, AS WELL AS
DEEPFAKE ELECTION CONTENT, AND
FULLY AGREE WITH THE AUTHOR'S
INTENTS TO GO AFTER SOME OF
THOSE MORE DANGEROUS AND
CERTAINLY WATERMARKING PLAYS A
ROLE IN PREVENTING THOSE, BUT
JUST WANT TO ALSO SAY WE'VE
TRIED TO ADDRESS THOSE ISSUES AS
WELL. HEAD ON, AND WE GREATLY
APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR'S
WILLINGNESS TO WORK WITH US, OUR
MEMBER COMPANIES, OUR
ORGANIZATIONS IN OPPOSITION, AND
WE FULLY COMMIT TO CONTINUE TO
DO SO. I BELIEVE THE BILL STILL
HAS A NUMBER OF ISSUES TO
CONTINUE WORKING OUT, AND I WANT
TO JUST VERY QUICKLY ADDRESS A
COUPLE AND, IN THE TIME I HAVE.
SO FIRST, WE WOULD PREFER TO
HAVE A FEDERAL STANDARD. I THINK
THAT SHOULD COME AS NO SURPRISE,
UNDERSTAND THE NEED TO SORT OF
ADDRESS SOME OF THESE STANDARDS
IN STATE LAW, HOWEVER, THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT IS MOVING
FORWARD. A LOT OF
NON-GOVERNMENTAL ENTITIES, THE
EU, ARE ALSO MOVING FORWARD. SO
THERE WILL BE A LOT TO LEARN
FROM SOME OF THOSE OTHER EFFORTS
THAT WILL BE PERTINENT TO THIS.
AND THEN, YOU KNOW, ALSO WANT TO
JUST HIGHLIGHT THAT THE
RELIABILITY OF THIS TECHNOLOGY
SORT OF EXISTS ON A SPECTRUM
CURRENTLY, THE PROPONENTS ARE
100% RIGHT. MUCH OF THIS
TECHNOLOGY DOES EXIST. MANY OF
MY COMPANIES ARE MOVING FORWARD
IN THEIR EFFORTS TO ROLL OUT
WATERMARK TECHNOLOGY AND
DETECTION TOOLS. BUT IN VARIOUS
FORMS OF UNRELIABILITY. SO
RESEARCHERS ARE STILL ABLE TO
BREAK MANY OF THE MOST COMMON
FORMS OF WATERMARKING. THEY'RE
ABLE TO INSERT FAKE WATERMARKS
INTO GENUINE, AUTHENTIC CONTENT
AS WELL. AND EVEN FOR, YOU KNOW,
SOME OF THE LARGEST COMPANIES,
THEY HAVE SUCCESS RATES THAT
WHEN SORT OF EXTRAPOLATED ACROSS
THE VOLUME OF CONTENT ON THEIR
PLATFORMS, WOULD RESULT IN
MILLIONS OF MISTAKES SORT OF
ACROSS THEIR, THEIR PLATFORM. SO
WE WANT TO CONTINUE WORKING TO,
TO ENSURE THAT THIS IS SOMETHING
THAT THAT WE CAN IMPLEMENT,
APPRECIATE THE AUTHORS
WILLINGNESS TO, TO MEET WITH US,
BUT AT THIS TIME RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSED. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING, MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS LAURA BENNETT, ON BEHALF
OF CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE ASSOCIATED WITH
TECHNET. AND IF I MAY,
COLLEAGUES STUCK OVER AND SENATE
JUDICIARY COMPUTER AND
COMMUNICATIONS INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION IN OPPOSITION.
MORNING, MISTER. CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS CARL LONDON, HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE RECORDING INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION OF AMERICA. WE'RE
NOT A FULL BLOWN, OPPOSITION TO
THIS. WE ARE CONCERNED ABOUT
SOME OF THE PROVISIONS OF THIS
BILL. THE INTERACTION, AS WAS
NOTED BY THE ANALYSIS WITH THE
PROVISIONS OF OTHER BILLS, THERE
SEEMED TO BE SOME COUNTER
OBJECTIVES, SOME THAT SEEK TO
REGULATE, SOME THAT SEEK TO HAVE
FULL TRANSPARENCY. WE'RE GOING
TO HAVE TO RECONCILE THESE BILLS
OUT. IT'S WELL NOTED, AND WE'VE
HAD A PRODUCTIVE CONVERSATION
WITH THE AUTHOR. WE HOPE TO
CONTINUE THAT OVER THE RECESS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON. STEPHANIE
ESTRADA WITH THE MOTION PICTURE
ASSOCIATION. WE'RE IN A TWEENER
POSITION. WE APPRECIATE THE
AUTHOR AND STAFF FOR WORKING
WITH US TO CLARIFY THAT THE BILL
IS NOT INTENDED TO APPLY TO THE
MOTION PICTURE AND ENTERTAINMENT
INDUSTRY. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
OKAY, THAT'S THE END OF PUBLIC
COMMENT. SO WE'LL MOVE BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE. ANYBODY WISHING
TO ADDRESS THE BILL, SENATOR
GLAZER. THANK YOU. SENATOR DODD,
CHAIR DODD YOU WANT TO REALLY
IMPRESSIVE COMMITTEE. AND I
THINK THAT'S WHY SOME OF US FEEL
WE DON'T HAVE TO BE HERE ALL THE
TIME. SO JUST CONGRATULATIONS. I
KNEW THAT WAS COMING.
ASSEMBLYWOMAN, I WANT TO JUST
SAY THANK YOU FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP IN THIS SPACE. IT HAS
A LOT OF US WORRIED AND
DISTRESSED. I THOUGHT THAT THE,
YOU KNOW, THE MUTED OPPOSITION
THAT WAS HERE TODAY IS, I THINK,
AN INDICATION OF YOUR HARD WORK
TO TRY TO FIND THAT BALANCE. AND
IN A NEW SPACE WITH NEW
TECHNOLOGY, I KNOW THAT IT'S
SOMETHING THAT YOU'LL CONTINUE
TO WORK ON IF THE BILL MOVES
FORWARD TODAY, I'M HAPPY TO MOVE
IT AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME.
THANK YOU. ANYBODY ELSE? I ALSO
WANT TO JUST THANK THE AUTHOR
FOR HER HARD WORK ON THIS, AND
PARTICULARLY THE NEGOTIATIONS.
SO MUCH IS RIDING ON THIS. THE
SAFETY OF OUR DEMOCRACY, AS WAS
STATED BY SOME OF THE WITNESSES.
SO I'M LOOKING FORWARD TO WHAT
COMES AFTER SUMMER AND, AND
READY TO SUPPORT THE BILL WHEN
THE TIME IS RIGHT. THANK YOU.
I'D LIKE TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
HIGHLIGHTING THIS IMPORTANT
ISSUE AND FOR ATTEMPTING TO
ADDRESS ONE OF THE MOST PRESSING
AND CONCERNING NEGATIVE
CONSEQUENCES OF GENERATIVE AI.
I'D ALSO LIKE TO RECOGNIZE THAT
THIS BILL IS A WORK IN PROGRESS,
AS WE'VE HEARD, BUT GIVEN THE
TIGHT LEGISLATIVE TIMELINE AND
THE ONGOING NEGOTIATIONS BETWEEN
THE AUTHOR, OPPONENTS AND
COMMITTEES, I'M CONFIDENT THAT I
CAN SUPPORT THE BILL TODAY
KNOWING THAT IF IT BILL REACHES
THE FLOOR, MANY OF THE ISSUES
THAT HAVE BEEN RAISED TODAY WILL
WILL BE ADDRESSED. AND I TRUST
TO KNOW THAT THERE'S NO ONE
BETTER THAN THIS AUTHOR RIGHT
HERE TO WORK THROUGH THE DETAILS
AND ULTIMATELY GET THE POLICY
RIGHT. I'M CERTAIN THAT ALL
PARTIES WILL CONTINUE TO DISCUSS
IN GOOD FAITH AND KEEP THE
COMMITTEE IN THE LOOP. AND WITH
THAT, ASSEMBLYMEMBER, WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE? I APPRECIATE THE
VOTE OF CONFIDENCE. I WILL DO MY
BEST NOT TO DISAPPOINT THAT, AND
WE HAVE WE'RE IN THE MIDDLE OF A
LOT OF NEGOTIATIONS WITH BOTH
THE TRADE GROUPS AS WELL AS
SPECIFIC INDIVIDUAL COMPANIES,
AND WE WILL CONTINUE TO DO THAT.
I WANT TO, AGAIN, PUT SOMETHING
ON THE FLOOR OF THE SENATE THAT
IS WORKABLE, THAT THAT CAN BE
IMPLEMENTED AND THAT PROVIDES, I
THINK, THE NECESSARY GUARDRAILS
THAT I THINK WE ALL KNOW WE
NEED. SO WITH THAT, RESPECTFULLY
ASKED FOR AN AYE VOTE. OKAY, I'M
THINKING THAT THAT'S, SENATOR
SMALLWOOD, THAT THAT WAS A
MOTION. GLASER MADE THE MOTION.
SEE SO THE BILL HAS BEEN MOVED
BY SENATOR GLAZER. THE MOTION IS
DUE PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
DODD. AYE. DODD. AYE. WILK NØ.
WILK. NO. ALVARADO. GILL
ARCHULETA. A ARCHULETA. AYE.
ASHBY. BRADFORD GLASER. GLASER.
AYE JONES. NGUYEN OCHOA. BO
PADILLA A. PADILLA AYE.
PORTANTINO. ROTH. A ROTH. AYE.
RUBIO. SALADO SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS.
AYE SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. AYE 6 TO
1. 6 TO 1. THANK YOU. SO PUT
THAT ON CALL. WHY DON'T WE RUN
THROUGH THE WHILE? WE'RE WAITING
FOR TWO BILL AUTHORS. WE'RE
STILL WAITING FOR, ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS LEE AND CALDERON, WE'D
LIKE TO FINISH OUR BUSINESS
TODAY, BUT WE'LL GO THROUGH THE.
MR. CHAIR, CAN I MAKE THE MOTION
FOR THE CONSENT CALENDAR? YOU
CAN. MOTION MADE BY SENATOR
WILK. CAN WE CALL THE ROLL ON
THE. I THINK WE I DIDN'T
ANNOUNCE THEM WHEN I WAS
CHAIRING, SO YOU PROBABLY NEED
TO ANNOUNCE THEM. OKAY. FILE
ITEM. THANK YOU. FILE ITEM
NUMBER TEN SB. EXCUSE ME. AB
2174 AGUIAR-CURRY 13 AB 2322
HART AB 2777. THAT'S ITEM NUMBER
15. ITEM NUMBER 18 AB 2991.
VALENCIA AND ITEM NUMBER 20 AB
3025. WE HAVE A MOTION BY THERE.
3027 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER BAINES.
WE HAVE A MOTION BY SENATOR
WILK. SECRETARY. PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL DODD. AYE. DODD. AYE. WILK.
AYE. WILK. AYE. ALVARADO GILL.
ALVARADO. GILL. AYE. ARCHULETA.
ARCHULETA AYE. ASHBY. BRADFORD.
GLASER GLASER. AYE. JONES.
NGUYEN NGUYEN. AYE. OKOBO OKOBO.
AYE. PADILLA. PADILLA. AYE
PORTANTINO. ROTH. ROTH. AYE
RUBIO. SATO SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. AYE. THAT'S
TEN. THAT IS TEN VOTES. WE WILL
PUT THAT ON CALL. I LEFT
EVERYTHING OUT. YES. WE'LL LIFT
THE CALLS NOW. DID YOU LIFT THE
CALL? DID YOU VOTE? SORRY, I
LEFT THE CALLS. MAKE MOTIONS.
GOOD. GOOD CALL. SO NOW WE'LL
OPEN THE ROLL ON FILE. ITEM
NUMBER ONE, AB 1768 GEO
COMMITTEE. WE NEED A MOTION.
THERE ARCHULETA HAD THE MOTION
AND SO WE'LL. SECRETARY, PLEASE
OPEN THE ROLL. AB 1768 MOTION.
IS THAT THE MEASURE BE RETURNED
TO THE SENATE FLOOR? DODD. AYE.
DODD. AYE. WILK. AYE WILK. AYE.
ALVARADO. GILL. ALVARADO. GILL.
AYE ARCHULETA A. ARCHULETA. AYE.
ASHBY BRADFORD. GLASER. GLASER.
AYE JONES. NGUYEN. NGUYEN. AYE.
OCHOA BO. OCHOA. BO. AYE.
PADILLA. PADILLA AYE.
PORTANTINO. ROTH. AYE. ROTH. AYE
RUBIO. SATO. SMALLWOOD CUEVAS.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. AYE. TEN
DOORS, TEN VOTES. THE BILL WILL
REMAIN ON CALL, WE HAVE FILED
ITEM NUMBER TWO, AB 1135.
ARCHULETA MAKES THE MOTION.
ARCHULETA MADE THE MOTION.
SECRETARY, PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL.
AB 1135, MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE. DODD A
DODD. AYE. WILK AYE. WILK AYE.
ALVARADO GILL. ALVARADO. GILL.
AYE. ARCHULETA. ARCHULETA AYE.
ASHBY. BRADFORD. GLASER. GLASER.
AYE. JONES. NGUYEN. TWO TWO.
OCHOA. BO. NØ OCHOA. BO. NØ.
PADILLA PADILLA. AYE.
PORTANTINO. ROTH A ROTH. AYE.
RUBIO RUBIO. AYE. SATO
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS. AYE NINE ONE 9 TO 1. TO
CONTINUE THROUGH THIS. YEA BUT
LET'S KEEP GOING. ALL RIGHT. SO,
YOU MEAN WITH HER NOW OR JUST DO
THIS? OKAY. SO THAT WAS 9 TO 1.
THAT BILL IS ON CALL, WE'LL NOW
OPEN FILE ITEM THREE AB 2375. WE
NEED A MOTION, MOTION, MOTION.
ARCHULETA SECRETARY, PLEASE OPEN
THE ROLL. MOTION IS DUE. PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE. DODD. AYE DODD AYE.
WILK AYE. WILK AYE. ALVARADO
GILL. ARCHULETA. AYE ARCHULETA
AYE. ASHBY BRADFORD. GLASER.
GLASER AYE. JONES. NGUYEN
NGUYEN. AYE. OCHOA. BO. OCHOA.
BO AYE. PADILLA. PADILLA. AYE.
PORTANTINO. ROTH ROTH. AYE.
RUBIO. RUBIO AYE. SATO.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. SMALLWOOD
CUEVAS. AYE 1010. THAT BILL HAS
TEN BILLS. I'LL CALL. WE'LL OPEN
UP FILE ITEM NUMBER FOUR 2389.
LOWENTHAL DOLL. ARCHULETA MADE
THE MOTION. SECRETARY, PLEASE
OPEN THE RULE. AB 2389.
LOWENTHAL. MOTION AS YOU PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE. DODD DODD. AYE. WILK.
AYE WILK AYE. ALVARADO. GILL
ARCHULETA. Ã. ARCHULETA AYE.
ASHBY. BRADFORD GLASER. GLASER.
AYE. JONES NGUYEN. NGUYEN. AYE.
OCHOA. BO OCHOA. BO. AYE.
PADILLA. PADILLA. AYE
PORTANTINO. ROTH. ROTH. AYE
RUBIO. RUBIO. AYE. SATO. SATO.
AYE. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS BEALL HAS
TEN. AND WE'LL PUT THAT ON CALL.
WE'LL OPEN UP FILE ITEM NUMBER
FIVE, AB 2402. LOWENTHAL.
ARCHULETA HAS MADE THE MOTION.
SECRETARY, PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL.
AB 2402 LOWENTHAL. MOTION IS
DUE. PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE. DODD.
AYE. DODD AYE. WILK. AYE. WILK.
AYE. ALVARADO. GILL ALVARADO.
GILL. AYE. ARCHULETA. Ã.
ARCHULETA. AYE ASHBY. BRADFORD.
GLASER. GLASER. AYE. JONES.
NGUYEN NGUYEN. NGUYEN. AYE.
OKUBO OKUBO. AYE. PADILLA.
PADILLA AYE. PORTANTINO. ROTH.
ROTH. AYE RUBIO. RUBIO. AYE.
SATO SERNA AYE. SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS HAS 11 VOTES. WE'LL PUT
THAT ON CALL. NOW. MOVE TO FILE
ITEM NUMBER SIX. AB 1296.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GRAYSON
ARCHULETA MADE THE MOTION.
SECRETARY, PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL.
MOTION IS DUE. PASS TO
ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY COMMITTEE.
DODD A DODD. AYE. WILK AYE. WILK
AYE. ALVARADO. GILL. ALVARADO.
GILL. AYE. ARCHULETA Ã.
ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY. BRADFORD
BRADFORD. AYE. GLASER. GLASER.
AYE. JONES. NGUYEN. NGUYEN. AYE.
OCHOA. B¢O. OCHOA. VÚI PADILLA.
PADILLA. AYE. PORTANTINO ROTH.
ROTH. AYE. RUBIO RUBIO. AYE.
SALADO. CIERTO AYE. SMALLWOOD
CUEVAS LOS 12 VOTES. WE'LL PUT
THAT ON CALL. MOVE TO FILE ITEM
NUMBER SEVEN 1511. SANTIAGO WILK
MAKES THE MOTION, SECRETARY,
PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL. MOTION IS
DUE. PASS, AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE. DODD.
AYE. DODD. AYE. WILK. AYE. WILK
AYE. ALVARADO. GILL. AYE.
ALVARADO. GILL. AYE. ARCHULETA
ARCHULETA AYE. ASHBY. BRADFORD
BRADFORD. AYE. GLASER. GLASER.
AYE JONES. NGUYEN OCHOA. B¢O
NUMBER SIX. RIGHT. SIX. SEVEN.
ITEM SEVEN FIVE. ITEM NUMBER
SEVEN. OKOBO. PADILLA AYE.
PADILLA AYE. PORTANTINO ROTH.
ROTH AYE. RUBIO. RUBIO AYE. SATO
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS NINE AYE. NINE
VOTES. WE'LL PUT THAT ON CALL.
WE'RE MOVING TO FILE NUMBER
EIGHT AB 1635. WARD THIS IS A
MOTION WAS MADE BY ARCHULETA.
SECRETARY, PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL
MOTION IS DUE. PASS AS AMENDED
TO APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
DODD. AYE DODD AYE. WILK. AYE.
WILK AYE. ALVARADO GILL. Ã.
ALVARADO. GILL. AYE. ARCHULETA
AYE. ARCHULETA AYE. ASHBY. AYE.
ASHBY. AYE BRADFORD. BRADFORD.
AYE. GLASER GLASER. AYE. JONES.
NGUYEN NGUYEN. NO. OKOBO. OKOBO
AYE. PADILLA. PADILLA. AYE.
PORTANTINO ROTH. ROTH. AYE
RUBIO. RUBIO. AYE. SARDO CORADO.
NO. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS 11 FOUR
TWO KNOWS. WE'LL PUT THAT BILL
ON CALL. MOVE TO FILE ITEM
NUMBER NINE AB 2832. WARD. WE
HAVE ARCHULETA. ARCHULETA MAKING
THE MOTION. SECRETARY, PLEASE
OPEN THE ROLL. MOTION IS DUE.
PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE. DODD. AYE DODD AYE.
WILK. AYE. WILK AYE. ALVARADO.
GILL ALVARADO. GILL. AYE.
ARCHULETA. AYE. ARCHULETA. AYE
ASHBY. AYE. ASHBY. AYE.
BRADFORD. BRADFORD AYE. GLASER.
GLASER. AYE. JONES NGUYEN.
NGUYEN. AYE OKOBO. OKOBO. AYE.
PADILLA PADILLA. AYE. PORTANTINO
ROTH. ROTH. AYE. RUBIO. HI RUBIO
I DO, I DO. AYE. SMALLWOOD
CUEVAS. THEY LOST 13 VOTES.
WE'LL PUT THAT ON CALL. WE'LL
NOW MOVE TO FILE ITEM NUMBER 11
AB 2237 BY AGUILAR CURRY. WE
NEED A MOTION. WILK MOVES. WILK
MOVES. SECRETARY PLEASE OPEN THE
ROLL. MOTION IS DUE. PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE. DODD. AYE. DODD AYE.
WILK. AYE. WILK AYE. ALVARADO.
GILL ALVARADO. GILL. AYE.
ARCHULETA. ARCHULETA. AYE ASHBY.
ASHBY. AYE. BRADFORD. BRADFORD.
AYE. GLASER. GLASER. AYE JONES.
NGUYEN. NGUYEN. AYE OKOBO.
OKOBO. AYE PADILLA. PADILLA.
AYE. PORTANTINO. ROTH A. ROTH.
AYE. RUBIO. RUBIO. AYE SARDO.
AYE. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS 1313.
BILL HAS 13 VOTES. WE'LL PUT
THAT ON CALL NOW. OPEN THE ROLL
ON FILE. ITEM NUMBER 12. AB
2802. MOONSHINE. WE NEED A
MOTION. THAT WAS SENATOR GLASER
MAKES THE MOTION. SECRETARY,
PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL. MOTION IS
DUE. PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE. DODD. AYE. DODD AYE.
WILK NOT VOTING. ALVARADO GILL.
ALVARADO. GILL. AYE. ARCHULETA.
Ã ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY. ASHBY.
AYE BRADFORD. BRADFORD. AYE.
GLASER. GLASER. AYE. JONES.
NGUYEN NGUYEN. NO. OKOBO
PADILLA. PADILLA. AYE
PORTANTINO. ROTH A. ROTH. AYE
RUBIO. RUBIO. AYE. CIERTO SARDO.
NO. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS LOST NINE
EYES TO NOES. BILL IS ON CALL.
WILL NOW OPEN FILE ITEM NUMBER
14 AB 2660. SECRETARY PLEASE. OH
WE NEED A MOTION ON THAT PLEASE.
MOTION WILK. WELL TO SAY I HAD
MADE THE MOTION. YOU HAD. OKAY.
SO NOTED. MOTION BY WILK.
SECRETARY, PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL.
MOTION IS DUE. PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE. DODD.
AYE DODD AYE. WILK AYE. WILK
AYE. ALVARADO GILL. ALVARADO.
GILL. AYE. ARCHULETA ARCHULETA.
AYE. ASHBY. ASHBY AYE. BRADFORD.
BRADFORD. AYE. GLASER. GLASER.
AYE. JONES. NGUYEN AB 2665 14.
ITEM 14. WHAT'S THE NUMBER?
2660. I'LL NUMBER 14. IT'S A
COMMITTEE, BILL NGUYEN. AYE,
OKOBO. I'M SORRY I MISSED. I
HAVE THE WRONG ONE. THEY'RE OFF
ONE BECAUSE THEY GOT CHANGED.
IT'S THE COMMITTEE, BILL 1330.
YOU MEAN WE'RE OFF ONE AB 2660.
OCHOA. BO. AYE. PADILLA PADILLA.
AYE. PORTANTINO. ROTH AYE. ROTH.
AYE. RUBIO RUBIO. AYE. SALADO.
CARILLO AYE. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS
THAT'S 13 TO 0. RIGHT NOW. BILL
HAS 13 VOTES THAT WE'LL PUT THAT
ON CALL BY ITEM NUMBER 1630. OH
WE'RE GOOD. YEAH ARE YOU GOING
TO GO THROUGH THE PILE. WE'RE
GOING TO GO THROUGH THE FILE.
SORRY GUYS. WE'RE JUST HAVE WE
OPENED A FILE ON NUMBER 17 AB
2816 GIBSON. WE NEED A MOTION ON
THIS NÓ. ALVARADO GILL MADE THE
MOTION, SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. MOTION IS DUE. PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE. DODD.
AYE. DODD AYE. WILK. AYE. WILK
AYE. ALVARADO. GILL. Ã ALVARADO
. GILL. AYE. ARCHULETA.
ARCHULETA AYE. ASHBY ASHBY. AYE.
BRADFORD. BRADFORD. AYE GLASER.
GLASER. AYE. JONES. NGUYEN
NGUYEN. AYE. OKOBO OKOBO. AYE.
PADILLA. PADILLA. AYE
PORTANTINO. ROTH. ROTH. AYE
RUBIO. RUBIO. AYE. SALADO.
SERIDO AYE. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS
13. WE LOST 13. WE'LL PUT THAT
ON CALL NOW. OPEN THE ROLL ON.
NOT OPEN ON 19. WILL AB 3006.
ZUBER. WE HAVE A MOTION BY
ARCHULETA. SECRETARY PLEASE OPEN
THE ROLL. MOTION IS DUE. PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE. DODD. AYE. DODD AYE.
WILK. AYE. WILK. AYE. ALVARADO.
GILL ALVARADO. GILL. AYE.
ARCHULETA. Ã. ARCHULETA. AYE
ASHBY. ASHBY. AYE. BRADFORD.
BRADFORD. AYE GLASER. GLASER.
AYE. JONES NGUYEN. NO. NGUYEN.
NO. OKOBO PADILLA. PADILLA. AYE
PORTANTINO. ROTH. ROTH. AYE
RUBIO. RUBIO. AYE. SATO NO.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. IT'S 10 TO 2.
PUT THE BILL ON. CALL OPEN UP.
FILE ITEM NUMBER 21. AYE. 2221.
I THINK HE IS. I THINK HE HASN'T
PRESENTED OKAY. I CHANGED TO
THANK YOU. THANK YOU FOR THE
WHOLE TEAM FOR YOUR HELP TODAY,
WE'LL NOW MOVE TO FILE ITEM
NUMBER 22, AB 3089 JONES.
SAWYER, WE HAVE A MOTION BY
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. PLEASE OPEN
THE RULE. MOTION IS DUE. PASS
AS. I'M SORRY. DO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE. DODD.
AYE. DODD AYE. WILK. AYE. WILK.
AYE. ALVARADO. GILL. ALVARADO.
GILL AYE. ARCHULETA. Ã.
ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY ASHBY.
AYE. BRADFORD. BRADFORD. AYE
GLASER. GLASER. AYE. JONES.
NGUYEN OCHOA. BO PADILLA.
PADILLA. AYE. PORTANTINO ROTH.
ROTH. AYE. RUBIO RUBIO. AYE.
SATO SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS THE BILL
HAS NINE VOTES. WE'LL PUT THAT
BILL ON CALL. WE'LL NOW OPEN
FILE ITEM NUMBER 23. THAT'S AB
3150 QUIRK-SILVA. WE HAVE
SEYARTO MAKING THAT MOTION.
PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL. MOTION IS
DUE. PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE. DODD. AYE. DODD AYE.
WILK AYE. WILK AYE. ALVARADO.
GILL. GILL AYE. ARCHULETA. Ã.
ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY AYE.
ASHBY. AYE. BRADFORD. BRADFORD
AYE. GLASER. GLASER. AYE. JONES
NGUYEN. NGUYEN. AYE. OCHOA. B¢O
OCHOA. BO. AYE. PADILLA. PADILLA
AYE. PORTANTINO. ROTH. ROTH. AYE
RUBIO. RUBIO. AYE. SATO SERRADO.
AYE. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. BEALL
HAS 13 VOTES. WE'LL PUT THAT ON
CALL. MOVE TO FILE ITEM NUMBER
24. AB 3211. WICKS I DON'T
RECALL. MOTION IS DUE. PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE, ABSENT
MEMBERS. ALVARADO. GILL ASHBY.
AYE. ASHBY AYE. BRADFORD.
BRADFORD. AYE JONES. NGUYEN
OCHOA. BO PORTANTINO. RUBIO
RUBIO. AYE. SATO 9 TO 1. IT'S 9
TO 1. THANK YOU. KNOW. I'M
SORRY. ONE MORE ROUND ON THAT
ONE PLEASE. YEAH. CAN WE GO
AROUND AGAIN ON THAT PLEASE. AB
3211. WICKS MOTION TO DO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE ABSENT
MEMBERS. ALVARADO. GILL. AYE.
ALVARADO. GILL AYE. JONES NGUYEN
. OKOBO PORTANTINO. BAIARDO.
SATO. NO TEN TWO. WHAT IS THAT?
THAT'S 10 TO 2. 10 TO 2. A BILL
IS ON CALL. WE'RE GOING TO MOVE
TO FILE ITEM NUMBER 16. THAT'S
AB 3193. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CALDERON, THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE AND WAITING FOR US AS
WE WENT THROUGH THAT. PLEASE
PROCEED. GOOD. IT'S STILL
MORNING. GOOD MORNING. Þ I NEED
THE MIC. ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU.
THAT'S BETTER, GOOD MORNING.
THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR. AND
MEMBERS, FIRST, I WANT TO THANK
YOUR STAFF FOR WORKING WITH MY
STAFF ON THIS. THIS BILL AND I
WILL BE ACCEPTING ALL THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS. THANK YOU.
AB 3193 WOULD AUTHORIZE THE
DEPARTMENT OF REHABILITATION TO
AWARD CONTRACTS FOR ASSISTIVE
TECHNOLOGY WITHOUT COMPETITION
OR ADVERTISING. IF THE VALUE OF
THE PURCHASE IS LESS THAN
$25,000. ASSISTIVE TECHNOLOGIES
CAN FUNDAMENTALLY IMPROVE THE
QUALITY OF LIFE FOR A PERSON
WITH DISABILITIES. THEY CAN
RANGE FROM SOMETHING AS SIMPLE
AS A WHEELCHAIR TO A MORE
COMPLEX TECHNOLOGY, SUCH AS A
SPEECH RECOGNITION SOFTWARE.
THERE'S A LACK OF VENDORS FOR
SEVERAL OF THESE TYPES OF
TECHNOLOGIES, AND FOR DECADES,
THE STATE HAS STRUGGLED TO
OBTAIN SUFFICIENT BIDS FOR A
COMPETITIVE PROCESS TO TAKE
PLACE. THIS HAS RESULTED IN
DELAYED PURCHASES, WHICH IMPACTS
THE CALIFORNIANS WHO RELY ON
THESE DEVICES AND NEED THEM
MOST. AB 3193 ENSURES THAT
ASSISTIVE TECHNOLOGY, DEVICES
AND SERVICES ARE PROCURED IN A
TIMELY MANNER. HERE WITH ME
TODAY SPEAKING IN SUPPORT OF AB
3193 ARE JEFF, TOM AND PATRICIA
LEITES ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA COUNCIL OF THE BLIND.
I ALSO WOULD LIKE TO THANK THEM
FOR THEIR PATIENCE ALL DAY AND
WAITING HERE AS, DURING THIS
BUSY TIME OF YEAR. GOOD MORNING
AND WELCOME. GOOD MORNING. THANK
YOU, MR. CHAIR. AND MEMBERS.
JEFF. TOM, DIRECTOR OF
GOVERNMENTAL AFFAIRS FOR THE
CALIFORNIA COUNCIL OF THE BLIND.
I'LL TRY NOT TO REPEAT. WHAT?
FOR THE SAKE OF TIME,
ASSEMBLYWOMAN CALDERON HAS
ALREADY SAID. I MERELY WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT THREE REASONS WHY,
AFTER DECADES OF TRYING TO
NEGOTIATE A WORKABLE SOLUTION,
THERE IS STILL A PROBLEM IN WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF REHABILITATION
PROVIDING A GOODS AND SERVICES
NEEDED FOR EMPLOYMENT IN A
TIMELY MANNER. WHILE STILL
COMPLYING WITH THE STATE'S
COMPETITIVE BIDDING MODEL
OVERSEEN BY THE DEPARTMENT OF
GENERAL SERVICES. FIRST, AS WAS
SAID, THERE ARE VERY FEW VENDORS
, OFTEN MERELY 1 OR 2 VENDORS IN
THE ENTIRE STATE. FOR MANY OF
THE ITEMS TO BE PURCHASED.
SECONDLY, THE BIDS ARE OFTEN
NEEDED TO BE VERY COMPLEX IN
NATURE TO MEET THE SPECIFIC AND
DETAILED NEEDS OF A OF AN
INDIVIDUAL WITH A DISABILITY. NO
TWO PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES ARE
NECESSARILY EXACTLY ALIKE IN THE
NEEDS THAT THEY HAVE FOR
EMPLOYMENT. FINALLY, IF BIDS ARE
NOT MADE IN A TIMELY MANNER,
UNLIKE PAPER DESKS OR THINGS
LIKE THAT, A PERSON CAN MISS A
YEAR OF SCHOOL, A JOB OFFER, OR
EVEN IF THEY ARE ABLE TO GET A
JOB, THEY MAY NOT BE ABLE TO
PERFORM THE JOB DUTIES AND
THEREFORE LOSE IT. THUS, I ASK
THIS COMMITTEE TO PASS AB 3193
TO ENABLE MORE PEOPLE TO BE
EMPLOYED TO LIVE INDEPENDENTLY
AND PAY TAXES. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU. GREAT HELLO
ALL. GOOD MORNING, CHAIRMAN DODD
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE. MY
NAME IS PATRICIA LUTZ AND I
WORKED AT THE DEPARTMENT OF
REHABILITATION, AND I WORKED
THERE FOR OVER 20 YEARS. AND I
WAS A VOCATIONAL COUNSELOR AND
THEN A SUPERVISOR. AND, MY, MY
JOB WAS BASICALLY TO HELP PEOPLE
WHO ARE BLIND TO BE EMPLOYED
THROUGHOUT THAT TIME. AND OVER
THAT TIME, THERE HAD ALWAYS BEEN
THIS CUMBERSOME PROCUREMENT
PROCESS, AND IT HAD LED TO
DELAYS IN US GETTING PEOPLE'S
ASSISTIVE TECHNOLOGY FOR THEM TO
GO TO SCHOOL AND WORK IN A
TIMELY MANNER. AND YES, THE
COMPETITIVE BIDS WERE VERY
CUMBERSOME AND CHALLENGING TO
OBTAIN. AND YES, EVEN THE UNDER
10,000 FAIR AND REASONABLE, THAT
THOSE METHODS WERE ACTUALLY VERY
CUMBERSOME AND CHALLENGING AS
WELL, WITH ALL OF THAT, I URGE
YOUR SUPPORT OF THIS BILL TODAY,
THE CLIENTS DESERVE A SYSTEM
THAT'S DESIGNED TO WORK IN THEIR
FAVOR SO THEY CAN BE EMPLOYED.
THANK YOU. OKAY. ANYBODY ELSE IN
SUPPORT? ANYBODY IN OPPOSITION?
I GOT ONE MORE SUPPORT. OH,
THERE IS ONE MORE. EXCUSE ME.
I'M SORRY. WELCOME AM I RIGHT?
IS THIS IT? CAN YOU. CAN
SOMEBODY HELP HER? MAYBE PUT THE
MIC DOWN. OKAY, MY NAME IS
REGINA BRINK, AND AS A AS A
CLIENT WHO HAS BENEFITED FROM
DEPARTMENT OF REHABILITATION
SERVICES AND LOST A JOB BECAUSE
OF THE LACK OF ABILITY TO
PURCHASE THE EQUIPMENT IN A
TIMELY MANNER. I'M IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. I DIDN'T
SEE ANYBODY ELSE AND NOBODY IN
OPPOSITION. SO WE'RE GOING TO
TURN IT BACK. BUT WE HAVE A
MOTION BY SENATOR ARCHULETA.
ANYBODY WANT TO MAKE A COMMENT
OR A QUESTION SEEING NONE. WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
ASSEMBLYMEMBER'S, YES, AGAIN, I
JUST WANT TO THANK YOUR STAFF
FOR HELPING US WORK THROUGH THIS
BILL. REALLY, REALLY APPRECIATE
THEM AND RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE. OKAY. WE HAVE A MOTION
ON 3193, ARCHULETA, THE MOTION
IS DUE. PASS IS AMENDED TO HUMAN
SERVICES COMMITTEE. SECRETARY,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. DODD I
DODD AYE. WILK. AYE WILK AYE.
ALVARADO. GILL. ALVARADO. GILL.
AYE ARCHULETA. Ã. ARCHULETA.
AYE ASHBY. ASHBY. AYE. BRADFORD.
BRADFORD. AYE. GLASER. GLASER.
AYE. JONES NGUYEN. WHEN? AYE.
OKOBO PADILLA. PADILLA AYE.
PORTANTINO. ROTH. ROTH. AYE.
RUBIO. AYE. RUBIO. AYE SARDO.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. NINE. 11.
BEALL. 11 VOTES. WE WILL. PUT
THAT ON CALL AND WE ARE GOING TO
CALL UP NOW. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
LEE, FOR A FILE ITEM NUMBER 21,
AB 3031. GOOD MORNING AND
WELCOME. GOOD MORNING. THANK
YOU, MISTER CHAIR. AND SENATORS,
I WANT TO START BY THANKING YOUR
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR WORKING WITH
MY OFFICE ON THE BILL. AND AS
NOTED IN THE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS,
ACCEPTED THE AMENDMENTS FROM THE
PRIOR COMMITTEE. THE BILL
CREATES THE LGBTQ PLUS
COMMISSION IN STATE GOVERNMENT
TO SERVE AS A STATE LEVEL FOCAL
POINT FOR A WIDE RANGE OF ISSUES
FACING THE LGBTQ PLUS COMMUNITY,
AND WILL SERVE AS A VALUABLE
VOICE FOR LEGISLATURE TO
CONSIDER POLICIES THAT IMPACT
OUR STATE WITH THE AMENDMENTS,
THE BILL IS MODELED AFTER
EXISTING COMMISSIONS,
PARTICULARLY THE COMMISSION ON
THE STATUS OF WOMEN AND GIRLS,
AND IN SUPPORT TODAY, I HAVE
CRAIG PULSIPHER WITH EQUALITY
CALIFORNIA, WHO WILL BE
TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT. GOOD
MORNING, CHAIR AND MEMBERS,
CRAIG PULSIPHER, ON BEHALF OF
EQUALITY CALIFORNIA, A PROUD
CO-SPONSOR, AS YOU ALL KNOW,
BECAUSE OF THE WORK OF THIS
LEGISLATURE, CALIFORNIA HAS BEEN
A NATIONWIDE LEADER IN THE FIGHT
FOR LGBTQ CIVIL RIGHTS, PASSING
LAWS TO PROTECT AND IMPROVE
ACCESS TO GENDER AFFIRMING CARE,
CREATE SAFE AND SUPPORTIVE
SCHOOLS FOR LGBTQ STUDENTS, AND
ESTABLISH SOME OF THE STRONGEST
NONDISCRIMINATION PROTECTIONS IN
THE COUNTRY. BUT EVEN WITH THIS
PROGRESS, OUR COMMUNITY
CONTINUES TO FACE SIGNIFICANT
CHALLENGES. JUST LAST WEEK, THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
RELEASED ITS SECOND ANNUAL STATE
OF PRIDE REPORT SHOWING THAT
HATE CRIMES AND VIOLENCE AGAINST
LGBTQ PEOPLE ARE ON THE RISE,
WITH 151 HATE CRIMES MOTIVATED
BY ANTI-LGBTQ BIAS BETWEEN 2022
AND 2023, AN INCREASE OF 86 FOR
86.4, LGBTQ YOUNG PEOPLE IN
PARTICULAR ALSO CONTINUE TO FACE
SIGNIFICANT CHALLENGES,
INCLUDING HIGHER LEVELS OF
DEPRESSION, ANXIETY AND SUICIDE,
AND AT THE SAME TIME, THERE HAVE
BEEN GROWING ATTACKS ON OUR
COMMUNITY NATIONWIDE, WITH OVER
500 ANTI LGBTQ BILLS INTRODUCED
ACROSS THE NATION THIS YEAR
ALONE, THE ESTABLISHMENT OF A
STATEWIDE LGBTQ COMMISSION IS
NOT ONLY AN IMPORTANT
DEMONSTRATION OF THE STATE'S
COMMITMENT TO LGBTQ
CALIFORNIANS, BUT IT WILL ALSO
HAVE ENORMOUS TANGIBLE BENEFITS,
SIMILAR TO THE CALIFORNIA
COMMISSION ON THE STATUS OF
WOMEN AND GIRLS, THE COMMISSION
WILL EMPOWER OUR COMMUNITY WITH
INDEPENDENT REPRESENTATION TO
ADVISE THE GOVERNOR AND
LEGISLATURE ON POLICY AND ASSIST
LAWMAKERS IN IMPLEMENTING
SUPPORTIVE POLICIES AND PROGRAMS
. AND WE BELIEVE THIS IS AN
IMPORTANT AND TIMELY MEASURE TO
ELEVATE AND ADDRESS THE UNIQUE
CHALLENGES FACING LGBTQ PEOPLE.
AND I RESPECTFULLY URGE YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ANYBODY ELSE IN SUPPORT? PLEASE
COME FORWARD. LIZZIE KUTSUNA
HERE ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ACADEMY OF CHILD AND ADOLESCENT
PSYCHIATRY IN SUPPORT, THANK
YOU. AARON TAYLOR WITH POLITICAL
SOLUTIONS ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA COMMISSION ON THE
STATUS OF WOMEN AND GIRLS, AS
WELL AS THE CALIFORNIA DENTAL
ASSOCIATION IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. MELISSA
LOVATO ON BEHALF OF THE COUNTY
OF SANTA CLARA IN SUPPORT
ANYBODY IN OPPOSITION, SEEING
NONE COME BACK TO THE COMMITTEE.
WE HAVE A MOTION BY SENATOR
PADILLA. ARE WE HERE? ASSEMBLY
MEMBER JUST WANTED. YOU ALREADY
SAID THAT YOU WOULD TAKE THE,
AMENDMENTS. WE HAVE A MOTION,
AND WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE IN
RECOGNITION OF PRIDE MONTH,
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR. AYE
VOTE. FANTASTIC. THANKS.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER, SO WE THE
MOTION IS DUE PASS AS AMENDED TO
THE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. DODD. AYE.
DODD. AYE. WILK ALVARADO. GIL.
ALVARADO. GILL AYE. ARCHULETA A
ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY AYE.
ASHBY. AYE. BRADFORD GLASER.
GLASER. AYE JONES. NGUYEN OKUBO.
PADILLA. PADILLA AYE.
PORTANTINO. ROTH A. ROTH. AYE.
RUBIO HI. RUBIO. AYE. SATO
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS EIGHT. THAT'S
EIGHT VOTES. PUT THAT ON CALL.
THANK YOU, THANK YOU. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER. WELL, WHO'S NOT HERE?
I'M HERE. PORTANTINO. ALL RIGHT,
ALL RIGHT. YEAH WE'RE SUPPORTING
SO WE DON'T HAVE TO WORRY ABOUT
HIM OR JONES. SO? SO WHO DO WE
HAVE TO WORRY ABOUT NOW? YEAH I
THINK SO. LET'S OPEN UP THE ROLL
CALL ONCE THEY CAN ALL LEAVE,
AND THEN WHO ELSE IS NOT HERE?
NGUYEN IS NOT HERE. BUT THEY
VOTED ON A NUMBER OF THEM, I
THINK. OKAY. SO WE'LL START OUT,
SECRETARY, PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR. ABSENT
MEMBERS. ASHBY. ASHBY I BRADFORD
I BRADFORD I JONES PORTANTINO
RUBIO. RUBIO I CERDO. CERDO AYE.
THAT SOUNDS GOOD AND THAT'S IT.
YOU CAN CLOSE THAT ONE. YEAH 14.
THAT CONSENT CALENDAR IS OUT.
YEAH. NOW WE'LL MOVE TO FILE
ITEM NUMBER ONE AB 1768. OPEN
THE ROLL. ABSENT MEMBERS. ASHBY
Ã ASHBY. AYE BRADFORD.
BRADFORD. AYE JONES. PORTANTINO
RUBIO. RUBIO. AYE. SARDO
SERRADO. AYE. THAT'S 1414. CLOSE
IT. CLOSE IT. YES. GOES OUT.
MOVE TO FILE ITEM NUMBER TWO AB
1135. LOWENTHAL SECRETARY,
PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL. ABSENT
MEMBERS. ASHBY HØI. ASHBY. AYE.
BRADFORD. BRADFORD AYE. JONES.
NGUYEN PORTANTINO. CIERTO
CIERTO. NO. I HAVE 11 TO 2. 11
TO 2. THAT BILL. KEEP IT OPEN.
I'LL CALL. FOLLOW NUMBER THREE
AB 2375. SECRETARY PLEASE OPEN
THE ROLL. ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALVARADO GIL. ASHBY. AYE. ASHBY.
AYE BRADFORD. BRADFORD. AYE
JONES. PORTANTINO CERDO. CERDO.
AYE 13. KEEP THAT ON CALL FIVE.
ITEM NUMBER FOUR. AB 2389. DO
YOU WANT TO CLOSE THAT ONE? YOU
COULD CLOSE ITEM. OKAY. BACK TO
AB 2375. THAT BILL'S OUT. EXCUSE
ME ITEM FOR ITEM FOUR 2389
LOWENTHAL SECRETARY, PLEASE OPEN
THE ROLL. ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALVARADO. GIL ASHBY. AYE. ASHBY.
AYE BRADFORD. BRADFORD. AYE.
JONES PORTANTINO. SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS SO WE NEED SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS ON THAT. IT'S 1212. THAT
BILL IS ON CALL. FILE NUMBER
FIVE AB 2402. ABSENT MEMBERS.
ASHBY. ASHBY. AYE. BRADFORD
BRADFORD. AYE. JONES PORTANTINO.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS BILL US 13
BILLS ON CALL BY ITEM NUMBER 16.
EXCUSE ME. SIX. I WISH IT WAS
16. AB 1296. ABSENT MEMBERS.
ASHBY. I ASHBY. AYE. JONES
PORTANTINO. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS.
BILL IS 13. BILLS ON CALL FILE
NUMBER SEVEN AB 1511 SANTIAGO.
ABSENT MEMBERS. ASHBY. AYE.
ASHBY. AYE JONES. NGUYEN OKOBO.
PORTANTINO SARDO. SMALLWOOD
CUEVAS. BILL HAS TEN AND THE
BILL IS ON CALL. ITEM NUMBER
EIGHT 1635. WARD ABSENT. MEMBERS
JONES PORTANTINO SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS STILL HAS 11 TO 2. THE
BILL IS ON CALL. FILE NUMBER
NINE AB 2832. WARD ABSENT
MEMBERS JONES PORTANTINO
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS STILL 13. NEXT
ONE IS THE SAME TO JUST OUT OF
CURIOSITY, ARE THERE ANY ASHBY?
SURE. IF I VOTED ON. BASICALLY
WHAT I'M INTERESTED IN IS THAT
YOU DID ANYBODY THAT'S HERE,
ANYBODY THAT'S HERE, HAVE ANY
BILLS LEFT OVER. SO WE'RE NOT
GOING THROUGH THEM ALL? YEAH,
JUST ONE SECOND. WHICH ONE? I
DON'T KNOW IF I MISSED HIM WHILE
I LEFT. I AM.
OKAY SEE YOU GUYS IN A BIT. AND
THANKS BOTH. THANKS. YEAH, WE'VE
STILL GOT TO GO TO THE LEAGUE.
NÓ 21. YOU'RE RIGHT. SO WHAT
ELSE IS NEW? SO WHAT ELSE IS NEW
? SO WE'LL GO TO FILE ITEM
NUMBER 21. THAT'S AB 3031. LEE.
SO YES. YEAH. WELL I'M 21. CAN
YOU OPEN IT? 21. IT'S OPEN ITEM,
ABSENT MEMBERS WILK BRADFORD.
BRADFORD AYE. JONES. NGUYEN
OKOBO. PORTANTINO SARDO.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS THAT'S A
COMMISSION BILL. LGBT
COMMISSION, ITEM 21. SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS I TEN ZERO. SO IT'S TEN
ZERO. THAT'S CLOSED. TEN ZERO.
THAT BILL IS OUT. OKAY. WE'RE
GOING TO GO BACK TO THE TOP. NO,
WE'RE. WHICH FILE? ITEM NUMBER
THREE. WHAT'S THE WHAT I WANT TO
DO IS GO THROUGH THE OPEN ITEMS.
OKAY YEAH. FILE FOR ITEM TWO.
OKAY. ITEM TWO 1135. SECRETARY,
OPEN THE ROLE. ABSENT MEMBERS.
JONES NGUYEN PORTANTINO 11 TO 2.
11 TO 2. THAT'S RIGHT. THAT BILL
IS OUT. 11 TO 2. ITEM FOUR FOR
ITEM FOUR 2389. OPEN THE ROLE.
ABSENT. MEMBERS. ALVARADO GIL
JONES. PORTANTINO. SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS. SMALLWOOD CUEVAS I
THAT'S 13 ZERO. IT'S OUT 13
ZERO. THAT BILL IS OUT. ITEM
FIVE AB 2402. ABSENT MEMBERS ON
FIVE. YES. GO FOR IT. ABSENT
MEMBERS JONES PORTANTINO
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS I 14 ZERO 14 ZERO. THAT
BILL IS OUT. NUMBER SIX 1296.
GRAYSON, SECRETARY. OPEN THE
ROLE. ABSENT MEMBERS. JONES
PORTANTINO SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS I 14 ZERO.
THAT BILL IS OUT. FILE SEVEN
SEVEN 1511. OPEN THE ROLE ABSENT
MEMBERS. JONES NGUYEN, OKUBO
PORTANTINO. SATO. SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS 11
ZERO. THAT BILL IS OUT. FILE
NUMBER EIGHT 1635. WARD ABSENT
MEMBERS JONES PORTANTINO
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS I 12 TO 2. THAT BILL IS
OUT. FILE I NINE 2832. ABSENT
MEMBERS. JONES PORTANTINO
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. SMALLWOOD
CUEVAS I 14 ZERO. THAT BILL IS
OUT. ITEM 11. ITEM 11. ABSENT
MEMBERS. JONES PORTANTINO
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS 14 ZERO. THAT
BILL IS OUT. FILE NUMBER 1282.
ITEM 12 AB 2802. ABSENT MEMBERS
WILK JONES OKOBO PORTANTINO
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS I 10 TO 2. THAT BILL IS
OUT. FILE ITEM NUMBER 14.
SECRETARY. OPEN THE ROLE. AB
2660. ABSENT. MEMBERS JONES
PORTANTINO SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS I 14 ZERO.
THAT BILL IS OUT 16 AB 3193.
ABSENT MEMBERS JONES PORTANTINO
SATO. SMALLWOOD CUEVAS.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. I HAVE 12
1212 ZERO 12 ZERO. THAT BILL IS
OUT. ITEM 17. SO ITEM 17 OPEN
THE ROLE. AB 2816. ABSENT
MEMBERS JONES PORTANTINO
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS THAT STATE
1313 ZERO. THAT BILL IS OUT.
ITEM 1919. OPEN THE ROLE. ITEM
19 MAYBE 3006. ABSENT MEMBERS.
JONES OCHOA. B¢O PORTANTINO.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS I 11 TO 2. THAT BILL IS
OUT 2221. PLEASE OPEN THE ROLE
22. EXCUSE ME. 22. AB 3089.
ABSENT MEMBERS. JONES NGUYEN.
OCHOA, B¢O. PORTANTINO. SATO.
SMALLWOOD CUEVAS. SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS I ZERO 1111 ZERO. THANK
YOU 11 ZERO. THAT BILL IS OUT
2323 3150. SECRETARY, PLEASE
OPEN THE ROLE. ABSENT MEMBERS.
JONES PORTANTINO SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS 13
ZERO. THAT BILL IS OUT AND 24.
FILE ITEM NUMBER 24 AB 3211.
OPEN THE ROLE. ABSENT MEMBERS
JONES, NGUYEN, OKUBO PORTANTINO.
WE'RE GOOD. TEN TO TEN TO 10 TO
2. THAT BILL IS OUT. THAT
CONCLUDES THE BUSINESS FOR THE
DAY. THE SENATE COMMITTEE ON
GOVERNMENTAL ORGANIZATION IS
GOING TO BE ADJOURNED AFTER I
THANK OUR GREAT STAFF AND
EVERYBODY IN THE ROOM THAT'S
HELPED FACILITATE THIS. THIS IS
OUR LAST COMMITTEE HEARING.
OTHER THAN A COMPACT OF THE
YEAR. I APPRECIATE ALL THE GREAT
WORK THAT YOU'VE DONE. ALL OF
THE YEARS THAT I'VE BEEN CHAIR
OF THIS COMMITTEE. I WANT TO
THANK YOU ALL VERY, VERY MUCH.
THIS MEETING IS ADJOURNED. SORRY
MAN, I KEPT FUMBLING, I KEPT
FUMBLING THE BALL.